bonjour à tous bienvenue dans le studio
piles et will du figaro le studio de
stream
on est en direct on est avec vous c'est
vous le voyez figaro live et on va
commenter avec vous le défilé du 14
juillet on va aller dans un astre
quelques secondes sur les champs-elysées
retrouver brume d'audrey et on va suivre
pendant jusqu'à midi ensemble ce nouveau
défilé qui est de retour donc sur les
champs-elysées on va répondre à vos
questions avec l'amiral alain kohl deux
filles l'ancien major général des armées
de 2002 à 2005
c'est à dire l'ancien numéro deux de
l'armée française
ancien responsable de la revue de la
défense nationale et président de la
société des la médaille de la légion
d'honneur et auteur d'ailleurs de ce
livre le ciel le sel par ben et les
étoiles que vous alliez chronique et
nicolas barotte bonjour balle et je les
lecteurs du figaro vous connaissent
puisque vous êtes le correspondant
défense du figaro on peut lire on va
demander d'ailleurs à adrien briand qui
va faire la modération pendant tout ce
direct avec vous chers internautes de
mettre en ligne et bien vos articles sur
le 14 juillet l'article qui présente le
le déroulé de la cérémonie et également
l'article qui revient sur la
l'allocution d'emmanuel macron hier aux
armes et on va y revenir dans un instant
mais où aller tout de suite sur les
champs elysées retrouvez brune d'audrey
et raphaël lazreg est-ce que brune et
raphaël m'entende
effectivement cette année le public est
de nouveau autorisée à assister au
défilé du 14 juillet vous voyez autour
de moi il ya quelques personnes qui sont
déjà rassemblés autour des grilles prête
à attendre le défilé sur les champs
elysées mais il a fallu remplir
plusieurs conditions pour pouvoir
accéder aux champs-elysées aujourd'hui
déjà il fallait un pass sanitaires il
faut être muni d'un passe sanitaire donc
un test pcr négatif ou alors un schéma
vaccinal complet ou encore une preuve
d'un rétablissement du coc vide
il fallait également porté le masque le
masque est obligatoire même en extérieur
sur les champs elysées et les jauges
sont effectivement réduite par rapport
aux anciens défilé notamment de 2019 ou
2018 la jauge et a été divisé par
presque plus de 2
nous sommes actuellement donc à côté de
la rue de berri et nous sommes dans un
périmètre où 340 spectateurs seulement
sont autorisés alors quand nous sommes
passés tout à l'heure la jauge était
déjà à 81 à 80 personnes dont il ne
reste plus beaucoup de place évidemment
donc ils vérifient le pas de sanitaires
une première fois et puis ensuite il
vérifie deux fois la fouille de naussac
et également le détecteur nous ne sommes
passés au détecteur de métaux
deux fois lors de deux contrôles de deux
points de contrôle alors le défilé va
démarrer normalement vers 10 heures tout
le périmètre des champs-elysées et aux
alentours c'est également fermée à la
circulation
les stations de métro sont fermées tout
est bouclé sur les champs elysées les
terrasses sont également interdites afin
de servir jusqu'à 14 heures aujourd'hui
et alors concernant les militaires
normalement il ne devrait pas porter de
masque pendant le défilé
là je ne sais pas si vous voyez sur les
images de raphaël la srec juste derrière
nous il est militaire donc ce sont les
militaires de la marine
il me semble ils sont tous masqués mais
parce qu'ils sont tous à stationner mais
normalement les 5000 militaires qui ont
prévu de défiler tout à l'heure devront
défiler sans leur masque eux on pourra
voir leurs visages vivre ça avec vous
merci brune pour ses premières
précisions on va revenir sur les
champs-elysées avec vous vous allez nous
faire vivre aux animaux nous raconter
puis répondre aux questions des
internautes vous pouvez poser vos
questions sur le site du figaro est
également sur youtube où vous pouvez
nous suivre en direct on est content de
vous retrouver on est là pour commenter
avec vous on a les meilleurs
spécialistes en plateau d'abord nicolas
barotte on a également l'avenir alcool
de filles qui est avec nous par skype et
on aura également en deuxième partie à
partir du début du défilé
florent de saint victor le responsable
créateur du blog mars attacks bonjour
nicolas bonjour emmanuel macron s'est
adressé hier aux armées on a pu le
suivre en direct sur fédéraux live est
peut-être ce qu'on retient en tout cas
ce qu'on a pu voir à ce que pu entendre
sur le site du figaro c'est la fin c'est
notamment un hommage appuyé au chef
d'état major des armées le général
françois lecointre
et bien parce que gérard lecointe que
c'était loin d'être des armées va
quitter ses fonctions il a annoncé mi
juin et il va faire c'est à dire aux
armes la semaine prochaine le 21 et le
président de la république a voulu
rendre hommage hier soir lors de la
traditionnelle garden party des secours
aux armées qui that i qui a lieu le 13
juillet à la vie des défilés et je pense
que le président a voulu un peu corriger
l'image qu'il avait établie au début du
quinquennat avec ce je suis votre chef
qui avait blessé une partie des armes et
qui avait conduit à la démission du
général de villiers n'a il fait preuve
d'humilité
il a remercié qu'il a rendu hommage
ouais on avait l'impression qu'il y
avait un énorme contraste entre le ton
de ce discours qui était presque un ton
dans l'humilité la modestie le profil
bas et celui il ya quatre ans qui avait
une
général de vider complètement là le
président a voulu saluer le travail des
militaires en opération
il a voulu rendre hommage à leur âme à
leur engagement et surtout il a rendu
hommage au chef des armées finale de
cointrin mais aussi le futur c'est mal
général burkhardt ancien chef d'état
major de l'armée de terre et ses
successeurs
d'ailleurs il a dit abandonnées des
armes et ont des chefs pour saluer tous
ces personnages est le mot qui résonne
fait écho à ce qu'il avait dit il ya
quatre ans on sent qu'il veut corriger
cette image
puis les quatre heures il avait dit je
suis votre chien absolument partout
d'automne d'autoritarisme en plus d'être
un acte d'humiliation
ça a été très violent c'était inédit
parce qu'à ce moment là le présent
[ __ ] être élu et il fallait faire des
économies au sein des armées il a promis
une augmentation mais à court terme il
fallait faire quelques millions
d'économies et général de villiers avait
protesté publiquement ses propos avaient
fui dans la presse je ne me laisserai
pas besoin comme voilà c'est assez assez
dur aussi c'est de son pain du jeu et ça
le président ne pouvait pas laisser
passer
le président jeunes avec un besoin de
légitimité
donc il a voulu rétablir l'ordre des
choses
rappelons une réalité c'est que le
président et le chef des armées sur wii
mais en le disant publiquement général
de villiers dit il faudra rappeler les
politiques à leurs promesses et aux
nécessités absolument mais en disant
publiquement je suis votre chef devant
le général de villiers le 13 juillet le
jeu va pas trop loin
il humilie le général à l'entrée ce
n'était pas nécessaire il ya une chose
dans lequel vous sur laquelle vous
revenez dans votre dans votre article
paru hier soir justement sur cette
allocution du président de la république
qui a eu lieu d'ailleurs au cercle
national des armées tout près d'ici
place saint-augustin et non pas à
l'hôtel de brienne à cause de la paix
aux causes de la pluie vous dites que
j'ai le tchad le président de la
république est revenu sur vraiment ce
qui a fait le thème de discussion numéro
un cette année qui est la tribune de des
généraux qui est le thème de discussion
d'après ce qu'on lit d'après ce qu'on
entend peut-être vous allez me le
confirmer mais le thème de discussion
numéro un chez les militaires en tout
cas chez les officiers oui ça fait
beaucoup parler tout ça ça a choqué à
plusieurs niveaux ça choque le devoir de
réserve du militaire donc chaque
militaire se demandait ce que moi même
j'aurais pu dû voulu parler après ça
choque sur la forme c'est que cette
tribune parue dans valeurs actuelles
étaient assez durs
même si sur le fond par les délitement
de la france d'autres l'ont fait mais
dans les termes c'était extrêmement
violent et ensuite il ya eu des centres
documente assez régulièrement
oui oui ça me fout qu'il y aller mais il
ya eu ensuite une réaction très dur de
la hiérarchie qui a voulu sanctionner
ces jeunes retraite c'est des gens qui
eux pèsent assez peu ils sont sortis du
nissan depuis assez longtemps et donc
voir les sanctionner en leur retirant
l'aspect très symbolique de leur type de
général ça a heurté aussi les militaires
qui se sont dits à ce qu'on tape à
cannes trop loin dans l'ascenseur est ce
bien nécessaire
et hier soir le président a voulu à la
fois sont nos deux armées un peu comme
objectif la preuve d'humilité mais
rappelait aussi des choses c'est que
l'armée ne doit pas être enrôlé c'était
le roi qui a utilisé pour un débat
partisan
on va demander si l'avenir le col de
filles bien avec nous d'avoir un petit
peu votre regard d'avoir votre
commentaire à la fois sur cette adresse
du chef de l'état hier
et puis également sur cet événement qui
était quand même assez inédit cette
année cette tribune des généraux d'abord
amiral bonjour merci d'être avec nous
comment vous avez
justement vu entendu écouter analyser
cette allocution du chef de l'état je
dirais bonjour à tous du port je dirais
que c'est une allocution normal
traditionnel est conforme à ce que le
chef de l'état chef des armées faire
régulièrement j'ai assisté à de très
nombreuses avec différents présidents
on était dans le ton habituel alors avec
effectivement la concomitance du départ
du chef d'état major des armées qui a
permis de redresser la barre comme l'a
dit nicolas barotte par rapport au
comportement le caporaliste 2017
mais c'était vraiment la tonalité qui
était attendu par les armées j'ai relevé
comme comme vous que il avait indiqué
que l'armée avait des chefs l'armée
produit des chefs de grandes qualités il
ya toujours un vivier de patrons qui ont
commencé par le bas tout ce qui est on
était sur le terrain ont l'air en mer à
terre et qui acquerrait d'autres
responsabilités si ça la force des armes
et on n'arrive pas au parachute et on
arrive en haut quand on a le droit vis
de toutes les marches à c'est la
première ma première remarque donc calé
face pour moi les fasse totalement ce
qui avait été fait en 2010 est à ce
point la tribune oui mais parce que si
vous voulez on peut pas toujours revenir
sur le le moi je m'étais exprimé en 2007
on pourra toujours revenir sur le passé
il ya eu un comportement qui était celui
d'un jeune président de la république
qui n'a pas fait son service militaire
et qui qu'ils étaient confrontés à une
europe
un mouvement d'humeur du chef
d'état-major des armées d'ailleurs c'est
une suite de de non dits et 2
de manoeuvres habituelles du ministère
de l'économie et des finances par
derrière et je souscris tout à fait à ce
qu'avait dit le général de villiers jeu
observe que les promesses du candidat
ont été tenus en matière d'orientation
budgétaire les années qui viennent de
s'écouler et qu' il n'y a pas eu un euro
j'allais dire de retirer ce qui est
unique dans l'histoire des roumains des
60 dernières années le budget de la
budget de la défense
donc je pense qu'il faut aller de
l'avant maintenant le jeudi la gardoise
alors d'oise et effacer le tableau et le
tableau est à nouveau vierge
alors justement on va peut-être sur
l'ardoisé qui était face et c'était une
question dardoise je salue d'abord les
internautes qui nous rejoignent
greg et christian léon greg nous disait
d'ailleurs que c'était pas forcément le
titre de général qui était retirée mais
c'était la possibilité de continuer
d'être d'être général en deuxième
section sont des généraux deux aces en
deuxième section qui ils peuvent être
appelés éventuellement en service et
donc si ils sont sanctionnés comme c'est
la procédure ne pourront plus être
rappelés ne pourront plus se prévaloir
de leurs titres dans la vraie vie tout
le monde continuera à l'abbé général et
on va revenir justement vers l'avenir
alcool de filles qui est lui amiral
toujours amiral
justement vous vous disiez
que les promesses budgétaires ont été
ont été tenus finalement le sacrifice du
général de villiers et l'action du
général lecointe n'ont pas été vaines
les l'argent et l'argent et l'argent est
venu et les budgets
qui finalement avait été dans lesquels
on avait taillé depuis la mi- la fin des
années 2000 ont été ont été rétablies
augmenté mais je pense qu'il faut
d'abord rendre hommage au général de
villiers les fonctionnaires jedir des
finances l'ont reconnu je dire
officieusement ils ont été coincés parce
cette démission et l'engagement du chef
de l'état a dû être tenu donc si c'est
pour moi le l'événement l'impulsion qui
a fait décoller la fusée c'est la
démission du général de vignes et donc
le général lecointe lui en tant que chef
d'état major des armées et des biens sur
pain là on rentre dans le champ de et
les prérogatives du ministre des armées
aidé par la ministre a pu conforter ce
budget mais il n'y a pas eu de pour
d'autres raisons il ya peu de grands
débats budgétaires ya il ya une bosse il
ya des échéances à venir on pourra en
parler mais je dirais dans l'exécution
des trois budgets précédents
puisqu'on ne pas tout à fait terminée
2021 ont pesé sur cette ligne dont
l'impulsion a été donnée par le général
délégué jeu je le rappelle on va rejeter
un petit coup d'oeil sur ce qui se passe
sur le champs elysées avec les
préparatifs des delà de la cérémonie on
voit justement les différentes unités se
préparer comme c'est le cas
traditionnellement sur sur la plus belle
avenue du monde
on va peut-être retrouver brune d'audrey
sur place il y avait 80 personnes autour
de vous est ce que on voit également
l'installation est ce qu'il ya d'autres
personnes qui arrivent car il va se
frayer un chemin
alors nous sommes toujours sur les
champs elysées en attendant le départ le
début de ce défilé qui doit démarrer à
10 heures pour l'instant nous sommes
donc avec je dirais un peu plus d'une
centaine de spectateurs qui ont réussi à
passer les barrages de ce filtrage parce
que c'était c'était pas si simple pour
ce défilé du 14 juillet beaucoup de
barrages ont été mises en place
notamment pour présenter le pass annie
terre mais aussi pour faire des fouilles
des fouilles des sacs et des fouilles de
nous de nos manteaux etc
alors effectivement ça dépend d un peu
des barrages filtrants nous on a réussi
à passer assez rapidement en l'espace de
cinq minutes
ici rue de berri alors que juste à côté
on va dire à 100 mètres un peu plus loin
sur les champs-elysées rue de ponthieu
il y avait un barrage ou où certaines
personnes certains français était là
depuis 6h30 du matin et attendent et ils
ont attendu plus de plus d'une heure une
heure et demie avant de pouvoir arriver
au barrage de la police
certains s'agacent et notamment des
personnes qui doublait il ya eu beaucoup
de d'éclats de voix et beaucoup de
tension parce que effectivement les gens
rentrés au compte gouttes et puis
c'était pas très clair un nid pour les
policiers qui filtrait ni pour les
personnes qui attendait puisqu'il y
avait des passages réservés aux
personnes munies d'une invitation
d'autres lieux d'autres passages
réservés au public qui n'avaient pas
d'invitation dont tout ceci n'était pas
très clair mais une fois qu'on a réussi
à rentrer comme nous ici rue de berri
les les spectateurs patientes sont très
heureux d'être ici ils attendent
patiemment de voir défiler donc les
militaires nos 5000 militaires qui
devraient défiler eux sans masque alors
que nous effectivement le port du masque
est obligatoire même si nous sommes en
extérieur nous devons le garder pendant
toute la cérémonie
et s'ils me cérémonie qu'on va suivre
avec vous brume merci pour ces
précisions
voilà vous voyez les premières arrivées
des officiels des ministres le porte
parole gabriel du gouvernement gabriel
attal on a croisé également la ministre
de l'autonomie brigitte bourguignon
alors effectivement comme il ya des
masques on ne reconnaît pas tout le
monde dans ce genre de cérémonie
d'ailleurs nicolas il y à la tribune
officielle c'est celle qui est aux
places situé place de la concorde
installé depuis quelques jours et il y à
un certain nombre de personnalités les
membres du gouvernement les ambassadeurs
oui et surtout il ya aussi les familles
des militaires des victimes
des militaire endeuillée qui ont
toujours une place particulière parce
que ce défilé c'est aussi en leur
hommage et il faut avoir une pensée pour
toutes ces familles qui ont subi une
perte un soldat qui est tombé en
opération donc pour la france et on va
d'ailleurs rendre hommage chaque année
aux héros du quotidien on va y revenir
peut-être une autre un autre point que
vous avez
soulevez d'ailleurs on vient de voir
olivier du soft donc ministres le
ministre du budget qui vient d'arriver
il y a une petite phrase de des manades
macron qu'il a envoyé à bruxelles hier
par rapport aux militaires parce que ça
c'est quelque chose qu'on ignore sans
doute c'est que les militaires français
ne sont pas soumis aux 35 heures donc
parce que les militaires par définition
ils sont employables à tout moment en
cas d'urgence en cas de crise et la
directive européenne sur le temps de
travail qui cherchent donc à encadrer le
travail des militaires elle contrevient
à l'esprit de cette disponibilité et les
chefs sont très claires sont en clair si
on applique en france cette directive
les armes et ne pourront pas remplir
leur contrat et donc on part de fer est
engagé et le président a été assez clair
pour refuser la directive merci nicolas
je rappelle que vous êtes correspondant
défense du figaro il y a une autre
annonce qui a été faite par emmanuel
macron hier c'est concernant les
militaires tu es mort
en non pas en opération mais dans le nom
dans le cadre du service et il aura
maintenant une mention qui est morte
pour la république
oui morts au service de la république
donc qui permettra d'encadrer et
d'accompagner les familles qui sont
endeuillées
parce qu'un militaire est tombé dans des
circonstances exceptionnelles
dans le cadre de son travail il ya
différentes catégories à ceux qui
tombent au combat mais on pourrait aussi
être victime d'un accident ou d'autres
choses dans le cadre du l'exercice et on
va y avait un vide juridique et pour les
orphelins pour les familles il fallait
trouver un moyen de leur donner une
apparation c'est possible on est en
direct on est avec vous c'est figaro
live vous le voyez on est au coeur des
au milieu des champs elysées plus tôt à
la fin place de la concorde avec les
images que
transmettre l'agencé france presse qui
justement est situé au pied de l'avenue
des champs-elysées qui est avec une
autre caméra sur les deux tribunes qui
font face à la tribune officielle et
puis également une caméra qui est à côté
de l'arc de triomphe donc vous allez
pouvoir suivre avec nous ce défilé un
autre dossier majeur c'est donc la fin
de l'opération barkan au sel
pourtant pourtant nicolas le général
lecointe avait assuré qu'on en avait
pour des années dans cette région et
humide et 2 sont vraies c'est que marque
anna s'achever au premier trimestre de
l'année prochaine ce qui était le
président et hier que l'opération par
cannes mais les français vont rester là
aujourd'hui on à 5100 militaires qui
sont engagés au sel et l'objectif c'est
de diviser par deux feux cet engagement
mais donc nous aurons toujours quelques
2500 militaires engagés au mali au sel
une autre forme dans une autre opération
cet autre opération
elle a duré encore des années donc quand
général de cointrin dit que la france et
les européens seront toujours là en 2030
c'est vrai d'autant plus que l'objectif
c'est de transformer de passer de
l'opération barkan façon française trop
sont sujets à une opération plus
européenne c'est à kouba qui est à
l'honneur aujourd'hui soit les champs
elysées et donc les européens à traire
takouba seront encore engagé au sec
pendant pendant très longtemps il avait
force takouba donc qui va défiler en
ouverture de la partie du défilé à pied
donc qui va être l'une des une des
dimensions de ces défilés on va
justement retourner peut-être aux
champs-elysées retrouver brune d'audrey
pour savoir un petit peu quel va être le
quel est le programme il est 9h 27 et le
président de la république
emmanuel macron devrait comme c'est le
cas traditionnellement ça n'a pas été le
cas l'an dernier mais
descente des champs elysées dans une
demi heure maintenant alors nous sommes
toujours nous sommes toujours donc posté
au niveau de la rue de berri sur les sur
les champs elysées sur les images de
raphaël il va il va tourner et vous
voyez nous sommes juste au niveau des
militaires delà de la marine nationale
qui vient de retirer ils viennent tous
de retirer leur masque il y a cinq
minutes donc vous pouvez voir désormais
leurs visages le visage de tous ces
militaires sur les images de raphaël
lazreg alors quand à quant à nous les
spectateurs donc de nous sommes un petit
peu plus nombreux à chaque minute
vous voyez désormais derrière enfin
devant les grilles il y a désormais on
va dire trois quatre rangées avant de
pouvoir être vraiment au plus près des
champs elysées
donc la jauge où nous sommes et limité à
3 140 personnes quand nous sommes
rentrés tout à l'heure il ya maintenant
plus de 45 minutes nous étions à 80
personnes j'imagine que nous sommes
bientôt près de la limite vous voyez
derrière moi donc il ya toujours ces
barrages filtrants par les trois
policiers menés par les trois policiers
dont qui fouillent pour la deuxième fois
donc les sacs et également il passe le
détecteur de métaux pour la 2e fois car
nous avions déjà un premier barrage
filtrant un peu plus bas dans la rue de
berry ou d'ailleurs a été contrôlé notre
pass sanitaire donc je rappelle que tous
les spectateurs ici sur les champs
elysées doivent être munis d'un pass
sanitaire c'est à dire d'un schéma de
vaccination complet pour le comité 19 ou
alors d'un test pcr ou antigénique
négatif août une preuve d'un
rétablissement du coc vide 19
voilà donc on attend on attend
patiemment c'est vrai que les
téléspectateurs sont sont très patients
et sont très calmes ils attendent ils
regardent les préparatifs qui se déroule
de temps en temps il ya des tests sont
des tests
cros sur les champs elysées donc ils
sont attentifs à tout ce qui se passe
devant leurs yeux ce défilé du 14
juillet pour la première femme depuis
l'année dernière nous avons enfin du
public qui pourront accepter
voyez bien voilà il est regardé ces
images en direct
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci bruno wiel avait ajouté le thème
gagner l'avenir
très la résilience la capacité
je veux courir
les tuer
[Musique]
voilà et on vit en direct justement ces
préparatifs avec justement ces unités de
la marine qui sont en haut de l'avenue
des champs-elysées au niveau de la rue
de berry on reviendra vers vous brûle
mais peut-être si vous êtes avec
quelqu'un
avec un de ses assistants sept personnes
qui assistent qui sont venus assister
qu'on l'a vu nicolas c'est un véritable
parcours
je ne sais pas dire que c'est un
parcours du combattant mais enfin c'est
quand même assez assez stricte les
surveillances il ya des consignes de la
part de la préfecture de police et du
gouverneur militaire de paris
il ya un an une sécurité qui est qui est
très nette on a déjà vu un passé tu es
un risque d'attentât contre chirac en
2002 voilà un ace qui inquiète aussi
beaucoup les polices c'est la menace des
drones aussi donc à un dispositif de
surveillance de l'espace aérien ba salt
qui permet de survoler de surveiller
l'espace cours au dessus des
champs-elysées et et assurer une
sécurité complète une question qui est
posée par patrick quels seront les
unités présentes brune l'a dit tout à
l'heure là
la évoqué tout à l'heure le thème de
cette année s'est préparée c'est gagner
l'avenir gagner l'avenir et en
choisissant ce thème là les armées ont
voulu faire le lien entre l'année
dernière la crise qu'ovide la résilience
qu'il faut surmonter cette crise et ce
qui va arriver peut-être dans quelques
années c'est à dire les combats plus dur
plus violent face à des adversaires qui
seront mieux armés et dans la mise en
scène du défilé
cette année les armées en voulu
illustrer des militaires engagés au
combat et les capacités de haute
intensité comme ils disent
donc on va voir takouba on a parlé tout
alla donc forces spéciales européennes
qui sont engagés au sel on a aussi par
exemple on a vu la marine on a deux
équipages de sous marins qui vont
défiler
l'émeraude qui a mené une mission hors
normes jusqu en mer de chine
ces derniers mois est aussi l'équipage
du suffrage le futur futurs sous-marins
nucléaires d'attaqué dans ces des
capacités nouvelles de haute densité
on va avoir aussi par exemple pour
l'armée de l'air mission skyros ce qui
va être mise à l'honneur même chose une
mission un peu hors normes de produits
sont puissantes comme ils disent par
aller très loin
incapable de mener des missions jusque
dans l'océan indien est évidemment
beaucoup de l'unité l'armée de terre qui
sont engagés possèdent ou ailleurs et
qui voit défiler c'est une petite
particularité un peu comme à la guerre
savent qu'ils n'ont pas voulu faire des
régiments constituer plus tôt toutes ces
unités qui sont composées de différentes
personnes qui se retrouvent sur le
terrain
c'est ainsi qu'ils vont défiler et on
voit les unités de la garde républicaine
se préparer on va retourner sur les
champs elysées retrouver bruno dray qui
donc
fait le pied de grue depuis ce matin
depuis tôt à braver le froid et le temps
qui est absolument pas clément et qui se
trouve avec dont des personnes des
français qui sont venus également
assisté au 14 juillet brune c'est à vous
oui je suis toujours donc au niveau de
la rue de berri sur les champs-elysées
post et donc on va dire à l'endroit où
nous sommes parqués avec une centaine de
spectateurs et je suis à côté de de
gérard et marlène bonjour marlène
bonjour bonjour gerra bonjour alors ils
sont venus pour la première fois voir le
défilé du 14 juillet d'où venez vous
diego californie san diego californie ça
fait combien de temps que vous habitez
aux états unis car depuis 1978 est alors
pourquoi avez vous décidé de venir ici
sur les champs elysées à pourquoi parce
que premièrement c'est la première fois
je viens voir le défilé en france
nous avons un mariage aussi alors on a
profité de l'occasion
exactement est ce que vous aimez est ce
que vous aimez l'armée les militaires
est ce que vous marine nationale de 63 à
j'étais sur le porte avions foch donc
marine nationale
c'est un peu votre famille dont
exactement et vous êtes post est donc
devant la marine c'est fait c'est fait
exprès nom du fils occasions on a vu la
chance tu as juste devant et vous avez
encore des anciens collègues qui
exercent
non merci beaucoup merci beaucoup je
marlène bonne journée donc voyez gérard
et marlène qui viennent donc des états
unis qui était de passage à paris en
vacances pour pour un mariage et qui se
retrouvent par le fruit du hasard
posté devant la marine nationale alors
que gérard et à un ancien de la marine
à tout à l'heure brune vous pourrez leur
demander s'ils ont connu
si gérard a connu l'amiral col de filles
qui a été à un moment en poste justement
sur sur le foch
bon amiral c'est assez c'est assez c'est
assez drôle d'avoir cette cette
coïncidence
je voulais revenir également avec vous
sur justement le losc annoncé tout à
l'heure
les précisions apportées tout à l'heure
nicolas au sujet des annonces qui ont
été faites par le président de la
république hier
d'abord ce bras de fer visiblement avec
bruxelles sur le temps de travail des
militaires et puis également sur cette
nouvelle disposition
cette annonce deux des personnes qui
tomberont justement dans le cadre de
l'exercice de leur métier et qui seront
donc mort au service de la république
alors servi de point et celui d'ae entre
guillemets bras de fer avec bruxelles si
vous voulez c'est une évidence tellement
flagrante que je m'étonne que le la
commission et puis se lancer dans ce
genre d'aventuré ya deux armées
professionnelles qui sont en dehors des
35 heures l'armée britannique et l'armée
française est une armée parlementaire et
syndiqué pour des tas de raisons qui
l'armée allemande
seuls les allemands son rêve
exceptionnelle qualité bien sûr mais
l'organisation est tel que ils sont
empêtrés et ne peuvent pas se projeter
rapidement quand des décisions sont
prises
donc si on veut une armée empêtrés
qu'ils à 17h ferme ferme le camp bleu le
bateau je sais pas ce qui peut faire à
17h en génération jours de mer ça fait
que deux mille quatre cents heures de
travail plus les 260 jours qui restent
au rythme normal on est loin des 35
heures donc chez suez c'est de la bêtise
monumentale le chef de l'état a bien
fait de taper du poing là dessus ou
alors il faudrait multiplier par quatre
et on trouverait des effectifs comme on
retrouve dans d'autres secteurs
sa celulle le premier point le deuxième
prix est beaucoup plus important parce
que on était dans le j'ose pas dire le
mot dans un angle mort de la protection
de nos militaires et autant avec les
opérations extérieures
je dirais il y avait aucune ambiguïté
sur le fait que quelqu'un de blessés ou
de tués en opérations extérieures ou en
opération ou tout simplement ressorti
c'est à tout un tas de l'objet j'avais
dire des dispositions autant le la mort
en service a toujours été quelque chose
de difficile à gérer ça avec eux
par exemple dans la police quand un
policier tué dans l'exercice de ses
fonctions
petit 6-2 à l'ordre de la nation donc
les enfants sont cupides de la nation et
deux avions cette difficulté à gérer
l'accident en service dans la découpe en
etc
c'est donc un point qui montre bien que
dans notre société on s'intéresse de
plus en plus ça à l'humain est que ces
pays ont contenu qu'au niveau le plus
élevé chefs militaires sont toujours un
peu battu là dessus mais bien sûr on a
chopé sur des questions subite de de
financement qui lui sont dues
actuellement des gouttes d'eau par
rapport à l océan de disponibilité de
nos militaires ou qu'il soit jeudi dans
l'est sur terre en l'air sur mer etc
voilà donc très bonne très bonne
initiative je parle pas du bras de fer
les 35 heures c'est tellement ridicule
qu au même pas non pas reprendre la
réaction justement de nicolas barotte
qui le commentaire nicolas barotte sur
ce sujet on rappelle que nicolas avant
que vous preniez le poste de
correspondant défense succédant à notre
ami alain bar lui et vous étiez
correspondant du figaro à berlin est
effectivement l'armée allemande a
d'autres
et régis par d'autres régimes que
l'armée française vous confierez celui
confirmé ce que l'armée qui est qui et
qui est piloté dirigé par le bundestag
pour toutes les décisions d'engagement
budgétaire et donc c'est pas énorme et
rapide peut être envoyée sur décision
présidentielle comme en france et c'est
effectivement une armée qui est très
encadrée avec des conditions sanitaires
très strictes temps de travail ce qui
pose des grosses difficultés notamment
pour les entraînements communs et c'est
surtout une armée qui ne va pas au
combat parce que à cause de l'histoire
les militaires allemands ne vont pas en
opération extérieure comme peuvent le
faire les britanniques les français qui
ne vont pas au combat et c'est pour ça
qu'ils ne sont pas dans ta cour a par
exemple parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas être
exposé au front donc ils font d'autres
missions comme dans la formation
ce qu'il faut en asie par exemple on
vient de voir alors que l'on voit le
ministre de l'économie bruno le maire
qui est arrivé on a vu justement olivier
véran le ministre de la santé est suivie
de l'arrivée de barbara pompili la
ministre de la transition écologique
alors effectivement bruno le maire pour
les armées c'est quelqu'un d'important
parce que c'est celui qui tient les
cordons de la bourse
et effectivement l'amiral col de fillon
va également martin sheen est pas la
meilleure école de filles
le disais tout à l'heure il ya toujours
un bras de fer avec avec le
le budget il y a une réputation mais
est-ce que c'est pas une réputation
surfaite que les militaires maintenant
savent manoeuvrer avec bercy jusqu'à la
démission du général de villiers la
réputation c'était plutôt l'inversé
d'avoir de bons chefs de guerre mais qui
savait qu'ils étaient un peu perdus
quand il ya des tableaux des tableaux
excel alors ça que depuis quatre ans le
budget des armées a augmenté toutes les
années comme c'était prévu dans la
programmation militaire donc
l'engagement effectivement a été tenu
que alors c'est une question comme l'a
dit d'amiral le rapport de force
initiale avec ce qu'avait dit effet le
général de villiers c'est sans doute
aussi parce que l'ami des armes et
florence parly est une budgétaire et l
ancien secrétaire d'état du banjo de
laurent fabius dans le gouvernement
jospin auquel sait manoeuvrer avec bercy
pas forcément très à l'aise dans un
régiment c'est pas une militaire de
carrière ou de coeur mais elle sait elle
s'est disputée avec bercy et ça c'est un
avantage et les militants a vraiment
servi pendant ce temps ça avance après
il ya toujours une tentation de faire
des économies mais ça que le contexte le
bal internationale est de plus en plus
de temps dit il on ne peut pas d'un côté
dire le monde est plus dangereux et
diminuer les moyens des armées il ya une
contradiction trop flagrante
on voit également la maison des anciens
combattants a juste de dos geneviève
darrieussecq qui a accueilli hier la
dépouille d'un
l'ancien général de l'armée
napoléonienne le général gul a et vous
avez tout à fait vous allez le récit à
retrouver sur le site du figaro richard
ferrand également et sébastien lecornu
ainsi que la ministre elisabeth baume je
pense que c'est l'amiral vandier le chef
d'état major de la marine que l'on voit
de dos peut-être et la ministre des
armées
florence parly qui vont accueillir dans
un instant sur les champs-elysées
emmanuel macron on va y retourner de
retourner dans un instant merci beaucoup
nicolas barotte d'avoir apporté sa
première précision je ajouté adrien
voyant les amis dans le chat que on peut
retrouver tout ce que vous avez écrit
autour de ce défilé
et vous allez encore écrire c'est pour
ça qu'on va vous laisser remonter à
votre bureau pour suivre le défilé vous
revenez nous voir à midi pour justement
se fasse un petit peu le bilan et voir
ce que vous avez retenu merci beaucoup
nicolas merci pour ces premières
précisions vous continuez à vous nous
posez vos questions vous continuez à
commenter avec nous se défiler ces
images en direct sur les champs elysées
on va retrouver justement sur place
brune d'audrey brune
il ya une question de basse maggio qu'on
salue et qui nous dit il ya personnes
sur les champs-elysées s'est pas
complètement vrai ça continue d'arriver
quand même autour de vous entourer de
spectateurs de français ou ou d'autres
des américains comme on a pu l'entendre
tout à l'heure qui sont venus assister
au défilé militaire du 14 juillet qui
devraient démarrer normalement aux
alentours de 10h20 on attend évidemment
à 10 heures donc le passage en revue des
troupes du président de la république
qui doit partir donc de l'arc de
triomphe et descendre les champs-elysées
en direction de la place de la concorde
alors nous nous sommes situés un petit
peu dans le dernier tiers on va dire des
champs-elysées au niveau de la rue de
berri je pense que le périmètre de
sécurité la jauge est presque atteinte
elle était limitée à 3 140 personnes à
l'endroit où je me situe
nous sommes évidemment tous masqués
c'est la condition pour assister à ce
défilé
il fallait également présenté un pass
sanitaire derrière moi les militaires de
la marine ont pu enlever leur masque il
ya quelques il ya quelques minutes de sa
désormais je suis en direct avec
emmanuel à côté de moi bonjour emmanuel
bonjour alors emmanuel est venu assister
comme comme tant d'autres à ce défilé du
14 juillet pourquoi vous êtes venus
aujourd'hui alors je suis venu
accompagner mon fils qui a eu la chance
d'être invité pour assister au défilé
depuis la tribune présidentielle il a
fait son essai ni service national
universel il ya quelques jours et à la
suite de ce service il a été donc invité
et vous vous n'êtes pas en tribune avec
votre fils donc non c'était les parents
n'étaient pas admis et est-ce qu'il ya
d'autres jeunes comme lui qui ont été
invités oui je pense qu'une dizaine de
jeunes qui étaient en tribune
présidentielle et une autre dizaine de
jeunes qui étaient dans une autre
tribune
alors vous êtes venu donc tout seul et
vous attendez votre fils donc à la fin
de de ce défilé pour le récupérer et
rentrez chez vous vous venez d'où alors
on vient de thoiry dans les yvelines
est ce que c'est la première fois que
vous assister à ce défilé à paris non
c'est la deuxième fois mais c'est vrai
que cette fois ci était un peu
particulière forcément avec cette
invitation et puis aussi avec locaux
vides et les gérer le parcours du
combattant pour arriver jusqu'ici les
nombreuses fouilles les périmètres avec
les 100 invitations
voilà fallait trouver son chemin est-ce
que vous avez mis du temps avant de
trouver une place ici avec nous une
petite heure j'ai eu la chance que de de
m'apercevoir qu'il une rue avec
effectivement des temps d'attentes
raccourci mais il ya certaines personnes
qui ont fait des queues pendant
plusieurs plusieurs heures et votre fils
il est posté donc au parquet en tribune
présidentielle depuis quelle heure il le
rendez vous était à 8 heures donc voilà
jusqu'à midi donc jusqu'à midi
absolument eh bien merci beaucoup et
manuel on va attendre donc le début de
ces défilés qui est prévu donc à 10h20
avec avant donc le passage comme je vous
ai dit du président de la république
les temps forts un petit peu qu'on
attend de ce défilé aujourd'hui c'est
évidemment le passage de la task force
basque force pardon takouba qui est mise
à l'honneur
et puis évidemment la police municipale
de nice qui devraient défiler également
en fin de défilé c'est la première fois
que la police municipale défilent lors
d'un 14 juillet c'est pour notamment
rendre hommage à ses policiers
municipaux de nice
cinq ans après l'attentât de nice et
puis un petit peu plus insolites
il ya également les youtuber mcfly et
carlito qui devrait être à bout
d'un avion de la patrouille de france
alors on verra certainement l'avion dans
lequel ils sont mais je ne pense pas
qu'on l'ait qu'on les voit d'ici je vous
confirme brune on n'aura pas les images
de mcfly et carlito en direct ça pas ici
en tous les cas qu'on les aura
d'ailleurs on avait fait un débat sur la
question et sur la présence de mcfly et
carlito à l'elysée c'était avec alexis
brisé et dominique reynié dans point de
vue il y a quelques semaines de ça et
vous pouvez le retrouver bien sûr sur le
site du figaro j'accueille florent de
saint victor bonjour florent merci de
revenir dans un studio du figaro ça va
ça va vous vous découvrez mais vous êtes
un habitué en tout cas vous avez tous
quasiment tous fait parce qu'on a
commenté souvent le 14 juillet avec vous
et donc vous allez vous nous apportez
vos lumières les lumières qu'on va
compléter pour être absolument
parfaitement avec celle bien sûr en
surplomb de l'amiral col de fille on va
revenir justement avec l'amiral col de
fille alors que les invités officiels et
donc le fils de ce
deux personnes que nous non d'entendre
se trouve d'ailleurs dans cette dans
cette tribune officielle on reviendra
sur ce service national universel amiral
qu'est ce que vous aller guetter pendant
ce défilé vous qui avez tant l'habitude
d'en voir vous qui avez assisté à tant
de défiler que sur la forme
les défilés 60 bien sûr un défilé aérien
des troupes motorisées détraqué la forme
reste la même le cadre général reste la
même ce qui est intéressant c'est de
voir si le message que veut veulent
transmettre les armes et gagner l'avenir
on l'a déjà dit se préparer à des
combats de haute intensité faire des
unités de présenter des unités de marché
donc pas des unités organiques
c'est-à-dire des lignes étaient
composées en tant que de besoin pour
répondre à un objectif opérationnel
données et non pas à celle de
l'entraînement habituel
on verra si cette image va ressortir des
j'allais dire des spectacles parce que
c'est un spectacle que l'on va voir
la deuxième chose c'est que là c'est le
marin pic qui parle le défilé des
troupes à pied et un défilé important il
montre cette discipline collective que
l'on retrouve en l'air avec un défilé
aérien et bien sûr sur mer à pékin un
défilé un défilé navale ce défilé montre
la discipline collectif car c'est très
important
chacun a un rôle chacun même le dernier
d'un carré de 160 personnes
le même vol que celui qui est en tête et
qui donne qui donne le pas ça se donne
une impression et puis bien sûr sans
doute moins que d'habitude les
applaudissements de la foule qui qui
profite de ce 14 juillet pour applaudir
son armée mais pour revenir à votre
question initiale pour moi aura-t-on
perçu dans ce défilé
au delà de la forme le message que
veulent passer les armes et sur le monde
dangereux dans lequel nous vivons et
pour lequel il faut être prêt à
affronter
des combats de plus en plus dures et le
racontant que le général burkhard qui
avait déjà lancé l'armée de terre / / /
cette tendance de la marine qu'avec un
plan mercator 21 avait déjà lancé cette
affaire l'armée de l'air qui depuis un
an un peu un peu moins d'un an et
l'armée de l'air et de l'espace sont
lancés dans cette nouvelle j'avais des
orientations mais qui correspond en fait
aux dangers danger mondiaux qui bâtit
sur qui pèse sur nous sur nos
ressortissants dont nos richesses un
tricot d'amis et tout un tas de choses
pendant que vous nous parliez amiral on
avait des images également du command
car qui se trouve en haut du champ des
champs elysées qui
et donc été amené au pied au pied de
l'arc de triomphe et on voit également
les personnalités qui continuent
d'arriver ici au pied des champs elysées
accueilli par la ministre des armées
florence parly florent de saint victor
on vient de voir justement dans le chatt
votre blog
marsatac qui a été dont le lien a été
donnée par adrien brillant à l'instant
on parlait justement du service national
universel
de quoi s'agit-il exactement le service
national universel est un acte fort en
tout cas symbolique du mandat
présidentiel du président macron
concernant les armes et une volonté
d'essayer de trouver un tout cohérent
pour autour du de valeur et autour du
diagnostic d'une jeunesse peut-être en
pertes de valeur et donc d'une réponse
apportée à un certain nombre de
questions sociales
les réponses la réponse apportée donc ce
service national universel qui monte en
puissance depuis quelques mois quelques
années avec des premières cohortes de
jeunes l'année dernière et puis cette
année des nombres qui s'accroît vise ou
espère en quelques jours une quinzaine
de jours à porter ou faire découvrir
certaines valeurs qui sont aujourd'hui
forte et que dans un imaginaire peut
être collectif on pense être forte au
sein de ces armes et les armes et un peu
gardiens de ces valeurs aujourd'hui un
débat
ça c'est la fiche ça c'est l'affichage
mais dans les faits c'est un peu décalé
et franchement ce les militaires sont à
part peut-être l'excellent général
ménard win qui dirige le dispositif sont
absolument pas trés trés les quelques
fans à 2 pour reprendre l'expression de
ceux de ce dispositif au contraire un
effet est-ce que les moyens associés au
service national universel donc un
milliard d'euros par an environ ne
seraient pas plus efficaces et mieux
utiliser ailleurs donc à une question de
moyens alors que l'on cherche à faire
des économies à gauche et à droite par
rapport aux conditions financières du
pays
il ya aussi l'argument de hesc en quinze
jours inculquer des valeurs
est suffisant est ce que remettre sur le
droit chemin et suffisant est ce que les
armes et finalement son gardien
intemporel de valeur
bonne ou mauvaise est-ce que l'armée
doit servir on peut tout faire l'armée
corps social disciplinée qui a le
réflexe quelquefois de garde à vous quoi
qu'on en dise est ce que c'est vraiment
son métier sa raison d'être sa son voile
à son devoir de de partir sur un service
national universel
l'atlant plus la filiation est un peu
compliquée comme le service national
universel sorte de prolongement du
service militaire un service militaire
qui à l'époque jusqu'à ce qu'ils soient
suspendus avaient une raison d'être
c'est à dire préparer des gros
bataillons des masses d'hommes prête un
choc majeur et donc avec une vraie
logique sur la durée du service
militaire qui était beaucoup plus
importante que les quinze jours et les
quelques semaines actuelles c'était sur
plusieurs mois une préparation au
maniement des armes une préparation
militaire
là il y avait une vraie raison d'être là
il y avait peut-être une cohérence
aujourd'hui quinze jours c'est sans
doute plus un stage de découverte
qu'autre chose donc des vraies
interrogations sur est ce que les moyens
qui sont mis un milliard c'est une
massette c'est de l'argent et les
résultats qu'on peut attendre de 15
jours de deux stages de deux modules de
découverte
est ce que ça sera suffisant d'où sans
doute l'élément mes remarques et les
questionnements des militaires
aujourd'hui sur la chaîne du figaro et
vous pouvez suivre donc en direct le
défilé du 14 juillet je salue tous ceux
qui viennent de nous rejoindre sur
youtube vous êtes au bon endroit avec
les meilleurs spécialistes florent de
saint victor auteur du blog marsatac
spécialiste des questions militaires et
l'amiral alain kohl deux filles ancien
major général des armées ancien
responsable de la revue de la défense
nationale on est avec vous on va
commenter et on peut répondre à toutes
vos questions je salue également sur le
site du figaro ceux qui viennent de nous
rejoindre notamment j'ai deux bords et
flight 94 bonjour à vous merci de
nous rejoindre vous commenter avec nous
on va également voir ce qui se passe sur
place place de la concorde également
autour de l'arc de triomphe ou renvoie
le command car du chef de l'état
installé à mener au pied donc de ce
monument voulu bâtie sous napoléon est
également ici à l'arrivée du défilé donc
devant le
la tribune officielle où vous voyez déjà
les éléments de la garde républicaine
qui sont installés avec en arrière-plan
l'assemblée nationale merci d'être avec
nous en est en direct on est avec vous
on va retrouver bruno dray qui est sur
place
alors brune alors qu'on voit brigitte
macron qui vient d'arriver aux côtés de
jean castex accueilli donc par les deux
ministres des armées la ministre en
titre le ministre des armées
florence parly et la ministre des
anciens combattants geneviève
darrieussecq brune tout est fin prêt en
eau de l'ach des champs elysées pour
voir passer le président de la
république peut-être une chose qui sera
intéressant de voir c'est si cette année
là le passage du président sera autant
chahuté qu'il a été dans les années
précédentes
la dernière fois c'était en 2019 oui
donc je suis toujours sur les champs
elysées à quelques minutes maintenant
des dizaines de minutes du début de ce
défilé militaire
je suis toujours postés donc devant les
militaires de la marine nationale est
entouré de public de plus en plus de
spectateurs nous entoure désormais
contrairement évidemment à l'année
dernière on se souvient où il n'y avait
pas eu de défilé pour le 14 juillet
simplement une célébration donc qui
était situé entièrement autour de la
place de la concorde et qui était
strictement fermé au public donc c'est
la province c'est là c'est désormais
aujourd'hui qu'on peut de nouveau
assister à ce défilé avec évidemment
beaucoup de conditions sanitaires qu'il
faut respecter nous devons notamment
porté le masque alors que nous sommes en
extérieur le masque est donc obligatoire
pour pour tous les invités pour tous les
spectateurs il fallait également
présenté un pass sanitaire au policier
qui faisait barrage et qui filtrait aux
abords des champs elysées donc je vous
rappelle qu'un pass sanitaire c'est un
certificat de rétablissement du coc vie
d'un test pcr antilles ou antigénique
négatif ou encore un schéma de
vaccination
complète du coc vide 19 alors les jauges
également par mesure sanitaire les
jauges de public était divisé par plus
de deux sur l'ensemble donc des
champs-elysées il ya seulement dix mille
spectateurs à la fois en tribune ou
comme nous sur les côtés qui sont
autorisés à l'endroit où je me situe
tout seul 340 personnes et est autorisé
il me semble qu'il n'y a plus beaucoup
de spectateurs qui filtrent je pense que
la jauge doit être totalement presque
rempli en tout cas on voit bien que ça
s'est remplie puisque désormais il ya
quatre ou cinq personnes avant avant les
barrières donc il ya un petit peu plus
de monde que quand nous étions arrivés
ce défilé du 14 juillet qui a pour thème
cette année gagner l'avenir et qui est
censée montrer notre résilience et notre
capacité d'adaptation et notre capacité
à se relever
dans cette période sanitaire compliqué
dans cette crise duco vide alors il ya
plusieurs plusieurs forces plusieurs
plusieurs corps de métiers qui sont mis
à l'honneur jean j'en citerai deux cette
année donc la tâche
la task force pardon takouba qui est la
commission européenne qui va être
envoyée au sahel donc il ya 80
militaires d'élite de cette task force
qui vont défiler en premier donc sur sur
les champs-elysées donc c'est à la fois
des français des estoniens il ya aussi
des belges des italiens et en toute fin
de défilé il ya également
enfin après ce presqu'à la fin du défilé
à pied en tout cas il y a également les
policiers municipaux de nice ils sont 45
à venir pour la première fois donc c'est
la première fois que la police
municipale défilent lors d'un défilé
militaire du 14 juillet c'est également
pour pour leur faire honneur
cinq ans après l'attentât de nice et
puis le dernier attentat
qui a eu lieu à la basilique de nice où
c'est également des policiers municipaux
qui étaient à pied d'oeuvre pour pour
arrêter le terroriste et puis un petit
peu plus un petit peu plus insolites
on attend également les youtuber mcfly
et carlito qui avait donné un défi donc
au président de la république et le
président avait accepté et donc ils vont
défiler à bord d'un avion sûrement d'un
avion de la patrouille de france
sûrement un alphajet alors on les verra
dans le ciel puis on verra surtout
j'imagine leur vidéo plus tard sur
youtube avec leurs impressions merci
merci brune pour effectivement rappelé
cet engagement de du président m'a du
président de la république à l'égard
donc des youtuber mcfly carlito alors
qu'on voit effectivement jean castex
l'est florence parly geneviève
darrieussecq remontée justement là les
champs elysées sans doute pour
accueillir le président de la république
qui doit effectivement vie kilic 10h
prendre le command car pour descendre
les champs-elysées on va sans doute voir
les images en direct si on ne les voit
pas vous aurez toute façon les
lesdites qui pourra être justement que
vous pourrez voir dans un dans un
instant on parlait du service national
universel
on est en train de justement on en
parlait avec vous florent de saint
victor le service national universel
c'est le lien entre l'armée la jeunesse
qui est un sujet qui tient à coeur
d'amiral col de fille il y à un débat
amiral justement sur le tchat
actuellement entre flight par exemple
qui dit d'un côté le service militaire
propose aux jeunes par le président
proposait aux jeunes par le président
macron permet au moins de raviver le
patriotisme des jeunes et à la verse
christian lui répond
c'est un service de 15 jours avec
simplement le souhait d'engagement des
meilleurs est ce que finalement c'est
pas beaucoup d'affichage service
national universel pour un résultat qui
est pas très probant et qui d'ailleurs
pour certains militaires pourraient être
10 qu'il est même peut-être contre
productif voire dangereux oui merci je
voulais intervenir en tant que président
de des décorés de la légion d'honneur on
est un peu près 50 milles et nous sommes
très impliqués dans ce lien entre la
nation et sa jeunesse mais pas de les
armer et à est par exemple nous avons
une dizaine de centres de chez nous qui
sont dirigés par des décors et légion
d'honneur en liaison bien sûr avec les
autorités administratives locales et je
soutiens que le 26 septembre nous
faisons des olympiades de la jeunesse
dans la cour des invalides avec 1000
jeunes arrivant de deux métropoles
d'outre-mer de l'étranger rassembler
autour de métier les valeurs de
l'engagement la solidarité avec bien sûr
près de 80 exposants c'est donc ce monde
associatif
intermedia les gens légion d'honneur
mais il y en a d'autres qui peut être le
support de ce s est nu dont la mission
initiale a pas été clairement défini
c'est pas un service militaire au rabais
ne peut pas être un service militaire
en revanche c'est un service de nature
citoyenne universel et qui doit donner à
nos jeunes garçons et filles
les ja dire les premiers fondamentaux de
ce qu'ils veulent la citoyenneté et les
décorer de la légion d'honneur sont
terriblement impliqué sur le terrain moi
je le peux je vois ça un petit peu
partout si le sujet c'est ce que je
voulais dire à propos de ses nus nous
nous trompons pas de cible
on ne refait pas alain service militaire
au rabais on donne des éléments de
citoyenneté à nos jeunes garçons et
filles de façon d'abord la vie dans
notre société avec des bases disons
solide entendu merci pour ces pour ces
précisions amiral
on va retourner donc sur les
champs-elysées envoyé jean castex et
florence parly discuter avec celui qui
va jouer les chefs d'état major et le
directeur général de la gendarmerie
nationale tout à gauche on voit le le
florence parly en grande discussion avec
le général burkhard qui sera dans une
semaine le chef d'état major des armées
remplacé par le qui sera remplacé à son
poste par pierre schill ils sont devant
une tribune assez particulière une
tribune habituellement ou les blessés
désarmé de l'année écoulée ou des années
passées sont aussi mises à l'honneur et
sont présents pour ce 14 juillet donc
c'est un petit geste une reconnaissance
de la nation importante et ils sont mis
vraiment aux premières loges au premier
rang
on les voit parfois blessés dans leur
dans leur corps dans leur tête
donc c'est un petit signe de
reconnaissance voilà qui qui qui est à
noter que ce soit les veuves les enfants
de deux de ses militaires donc là on
voit aussi le dernier défilé du chef
d'état major de l'armée de l'air qui va
être remplacé le général david tout à
fait qui remplacé par le général mille
dans quelques dans quelques jours
l'annoncé a été faite hier donc le
général la vigne comme l'avait dit
l'amiral qui a lancé l'armée de l'air
elle aussi vers le vrd des combats plus
compliqué avec un plan stratégique faire
face qui est déjà dans plusieurs
itérations pour essayer de remonter le
niveau d'exigence encore plus élevé de
l'armée de l'air et de l'espace
maintenant voilà pour pousser plus haut
les les exigences donc le plan faire
face un peu le le le signe en tout cas
le la partie importante de du général
lavigne donc qui sera bientôt remplacé
par le général 2000 qui en charge des
opérations donc très au fait aujourd'hui
des tenants et des aboutissants et de ce
que les armes et rencontres sur les
terrains d'opération et l'exigence qui
est de plus en plus demandée lors de ces
opérations alors vous le voyez peut-être
pas en direct mais nous on a 2 le retour
de ce qui se passe tout en haut de cette
image c'est-à-dire en niveau de l'arc de
triomphe le
président de la république et le
maquereau qui vient d'être accueilli
chaleureusement avec accolade par le
chef d'état major des armées
tout médailles 2 or le général françois
lecointre
et visiblement le gouverneur militaire
de paris le général et christophe abad
donc emmanuel macron devrait monter dans
les secondes qui viennent dans ce fameux
véhicule il est en train de le faire
après avoir donné on ne sait pas trop
quoi
quelque chose qui semble être son aide
de camp et voilà donc le président de la
république aux côtés du général lecointe
dernier défilé pour l'actuel chef d'état
major des armées
derrière les sourires florent il y a
quand même eu quelque chose qui un
événement qui a un peu terni
les dernières semaines 2
le nom delà de l'actuelle cema qui a été
cette tribune je ne vois là un moment
compliqué à gérer dans les rapports
politico-militaire toujours des rapports
qui sont en construction en évolution
permanente fait de phase d'apaisement et
de phase de tensions nicolas barreau
temps en parlait beaucoup il ya quelques
minutes
voilà donc une fin de fin de mandat pour
le chef d'état major des armées est
difficile il faut tenir là il faut tenir
la barque réussira à maintenir l'unité
désarmé je pense que c'était ce qu'il ce
qui a conduit ces réactions parfois
fortes mais cette envie de le le bien le
plus important c'est les armes et soudés
pour le pour assurer leur mission de
défense de la france mais c'est vrai que
c'est dans des moments compliqués entre
pour juger les bonnes prises de paroles
jugées les bonnes réactions jugées
l'image renvoyée
voilà donc on dire un schéma qui de lui
même avait demandé de partir d'or qu'il
avait proposé au président et qui
voulait tourner la page peut-être
sentait qu'il y avait peut-être besoin
un peu de sang neuf et dîners noël à la
tête des armées
en plus de ne pas vouloir être le
général ou en tout cas l'avoir l'image
d'être le général du président est
d'être suzuki les armées sont la
continuité quel que soit le président en
exercice donc il tournera donc la page
dans d'ici quelques semaines
après trois années pleines et chargé que
ce soit sur le plan des opérations ou
sur le plan des rapports politico
militaire le chef d'état-major des
armées étant vraiment au coeur de ces
rapports politico militaire on voit
justement voir dans un instant à l'autre
l'arrivée cette fois ci dû
président de la république et du chef
d'état major des armées
au bas des champs-elysées une question
peut-être de romain quels sont les pays
alliés qui sont présents aujourd'hui
c'est ceux notamment qui sont avec la
task force que l'acné combat tout à fait
alors la taskforce takouba dont beaucoup
d'éléments sont de retour du du sahel
ceux qui défilent était encore il ya
quelques semaines dans les sables
sahélien donc au sein de la task force
takouba des éléments moteurs fo sont
l'estonie et la république tchèque donc
l'estonie petit pays mais gros
engagement au sahel
voilà la république tchèque et puis on
verra aussi des représentants de la
belgique de l'italie des pays qui ont
pour le moment parfois on voyait juste
encore des officiers des officiers de
liaison et demain normalement en voiron
des forces spéciales des unités de
forces spéciales qui seront sur le
terrain
les suédois qui ont envoyé des des
hôpitaux et des moyens de transport pour
cette taskforce takouba la task force
étant vraiment regroupement de toutes
les capacités nécessaires aux opérations
donc ça soit des hommes au sol donc les
forces spéciales vraiment sur le terrain
mais aussi des transmissions si le
sanitaire aussi la logistique aussi la
partie commandement et tous et tous ces
pays dans des proportions différentes
apporte quelques éléments donc ça c'est
la gauche lagos mise en valeur et en
avant des alliés ce sera vraiment dans
la tasse first à quoi et peut-être aussi
quelques dans les écoles ou dans les
aborder des avions des hélicoptères des
officiers de liaison qui sont en
permanence en permanence il ya des
dizaines et dizaines d'officiers de
liaison dans les régiments dont les
bases aériennes sur les bateaux d'allier
qui passe une année deux années inséré
dans les escadrons à découvrir
à découvrir de près l'armée française
donc chaque 14 juillet certains certains
pilotes par exemple britanniques ou
américains peuvent se retrouver aux
commandes
dans les écoles on veut il faudra
observer si il n'y a pas des uniformes
un peu différent montrant la présence ou
de nos fichiers ou de stagiaires ou de
nous mêmes de professeurs dans le corps
professoral quelquefois des étrangers
qui viennent une ou deux années
enseigner dans les centres de formation
en france on a également les images
voilà qui reviennent à redon et on voit
donc elle est magnifique unités pardon
d'épithètes on dort pas en donner mais
delà de la garde républicaine
alors là c'est la partie à parra de la
garde si on peut donner un épithète
c'est là c'est ce qu'on appelle la
grande escorte
voilà donc c'est toute décoration tout
uniforme dehors donc la garde
républicaine voilà qui entoure le chef
d'état-major des armées ainsi que le
chef des armées le président donc voilà
la grande escorte qui descend les champs
elysées passant en revue les troupes
les les unités qui vont défiler les unes
après les autres et drapeaux bessin bon
voilà drapeaux les drapeaux français
baisser
par ce signe de 2 les armées sont sous
l'autorité du politique et donc le 14
juillet dans cette cérémonie voilà
rappelle aussi cette ce lien votre va
laisser faire vivre justement ces
instants voilà avec le président de la
république on voit le président de la
république d'ailleurs salué les
personnes qui sont aux nombres réduite
sur le
sur le champs elysées avec une jauge qui
a été qui a été nettement réduits de
moitié nous disait tout à l'heure
brune d'audrey on va peut-être aller la
retrouver sur place pour savoir comment
c'est a été accueilli le passage du
cortège et du dispositif à son niveau
rue de berri est ce que brune vous nous
entendez
alors petit a bola on va retrouver brune
voilà on est en dispositifs avis ouest
on qu'on a un petit décalage à chaque
fois quand on se parle mais voilà brume
comment s'est passé brune comment s'est
passée justement comment a été
accueillie et comment les gens ont réagi
au passage du cortège présidentiel
mais alors on vient de voir le président
de la république et le général le
cloître qui était qui viennent de passer
en revue toutes les troupes escortaient
donc par la garde républicaine ainsi que
que des véhicules motorisés des motos
alors dans notre là où nous sommes
parqués donc on va dire à l'angle des
champs elysées de la rue de berri
l'ambiance est plutôt calme et studieuse
comme le président est passé beaucoup de
téléphones ont été relevés ou
d'appareils photo pour prendre en photo
le président de la république qui a
tourné la tête vers vers nous au monde
son passage et nous a salué de la main
pas de pas de huées donc cette fois ci
un accueil sobre en accueille calme on
se rappelle qu'en 2019 effectivement
emmanuel macron avait été accueilli par
des huées des huées augment de de son
passage du passage en revue des troupes
un groupe de gilet jaune était notamment
prévu présent avec des figures du
mouvement qui ont été a été arrêté aux
abords des champs elysées à l'époque
alors là où nous sommes il n'y a pas eu
de but et il ya eu un seul
applaudissements qui était un petit peu
plus loin et puis j'ai entendu
manu c'est tout j'ai rien entendu de
spéciale les gens attendent surtout je
pense
les militaires qui devraient pas tarder
le défi limitèrent qui va démarrer
bientôt et que vous pourrez suivre en
direct sur figaro malades
merci beaucoup brune s'est toujours
effectivement intéressant de prendre le
pouls justement de ce passage ça paraît
complètement anecdotique mais en fait
quand on regarde sur les années on voit
qu'il ya différentes différentes
ambiances
il n'y a pas un passage de françois
hollande qui pouvait se faire sans qu'il
y ait des huées en 2017 quand emmanuel
macron et telus alors même qu'il vient
d'humilier le général de villiers et
dont on voit le visage fermé qui sera
l'image de ce premier défilé là à
l'époque le président de la république
avait été ovationné
et puis ensuite il ya eu
et gilet jaune avec effectivement ces
mouvements et même en 2010 9 des scènes
littéralement d'un archi sur les
champs-elysées tout de suite après le la
fin du défilé alors que emmanuel macron
va arriver dans un instant où est déjà
arrivé on va regarder je vais regarder
sur mon retour écran non pas encore en
tous les cas pas sur les images que la
fp nous ramène le cortège de la garde
républicaine et un train d'arriver
devant le dispositif devant le vin
devant la légion étrangère
on va retourner voir le l'amiral gaulle
de fille amiral on parlait justement du
cema des dernières semaines du cema qui
ont été agités par la polémique autour
de la tribune des militaires il ya un
autre point que souligne françois-xavier
bourmaud qui est journaliste au service
politique du figaro ce matin donc dans
le dans le figaro que articles qu'on
peut retrouver sur le site et dans le
chat c'est que il y aura eu trois chefs
d'état major en moins de cinq ans dans
le mandat des macros c'est assez inédit
quand même d'avoir ce tel un tel turn
over de deux de ses mains non les chefs
d'état-major de l'armée depuis depuis
une trentaine d'années sans mandat entre
3 et 4 on a un ou deux qui ont fait 5
ans et un café un petit peu moins donc
si la durée normale c'est la durée
j'allais dire d'usure de désir d'un chef
d'état major des armées donc on est on
est dans le dans le cycle puisque vous
avez été le bras droit du chef d'état
major des armées qui était le 5 mai j'ai
même commencé avec le général crèche
dans sage le plus chic logique les deux
points à 4 ans et le général lecointre
est tout à fait dans le fixe alors quand
vous taj et 4 ans dans cinq ans de
mandat présidentiel à vous avez sur deux
soit 3,3 chef d'état-major regard rien
de particulier à dire là-dessus le le
deuxième fois que vous vous m'indiquer
je suis de la tribune deux généraux
cette tribune pour moi je me suis déjà
exprimé par écrit le les signataires à
la demande est telle en retraite de ja
sont pas rendus compte que le fait
d'être militaire allait être
sur-interprétée j'observe que quand le
chef de l'état a supprimé les grands
corps de l'état 60 préfet ont fait un
article de fond je crois que c'est dans
le monde
il n'a déclenché aucune remarque dans
aucun média que les des ambassadeurs etc
selon le figaro aussi à des tribunes de
préfet dans le figaro non mais alors que
alors que j'allais dire si à la fois
flatteur pour les militaires de voir que
70 ans 81 ans même d'autres qui étaient
plus âgés
on pensait plus mais aussitôt il ya des
réactions politiques
ça montre que l'armée vraiment au coeur
de la nation avec la nation envers vie
quand la bande armée pain mais mais pour
moi cela n'a rien déclenché dans les
armées dans l'armée d'actifs celle qui
celle qui agit web pour les français et
vis versa fait qu'une une petite
vaguelette une risée sur un plan d'eau
qui est resté complètement calme c'est
vrai que la surinterprétation a été
faite par le fait que bien sûr des
partis les deux partis des extrêmes
elle est fille et le rassemblement
national ont réagi aussitôt ce qui a
entraîné une course en sac elle pourra
pour récupérer le dispositif mais je
crois qu'il faut pas sûr voilà on voit
le président de la république et le chef
d'état-major des armées justement arrivé
avec la garde républicaine
entouré de la garde républicaine sur le
la place de la concorde actuellement on
va
continuez à regarder ces images et
retrouver peut-être brune d'audrey tout
en regardant ces images qui est avec
des personnes qui sont sur place en
train de regarder ce défilé qui doit
également
s'ébranlait au dessus au niveau du bloc
de triomphe alors que voilà donc brune
était là je pense en train de
régler les derniers détails des
dernières modalités de cette interview
on est avec vous on est en direct
on continue de répondre à vos questions
justement
e
ce que disait l'amiral col de filles à
l'instant florent remet en question un
petit peu cette remarque de flight qui
nous dit la présence de trois chefs
d'états majors montrent que macro à
essayer de bousculer l'institution
militaire par des mesures fortes
non c'est on est on est plutôt c'est une
illusion d'optique on est plutôt dans
quelque chose dont c'est assez classique
quand on dès les premiers jours il ya un
nouveau chef d'état-major danse on en a
dans les conditions qu'on connaît sur un
mandat présidentiel de cinq ans c'est
normal que rapidement il y en ait trois
le général de villiers par très
rapidement entre lee mais voilà comme le
dit très bien le général l'amiral colle
les filles voilà trois ans cinq ans
voilà et on voit donc là justement le nm
macron donc qui me posait la main sur le
bras du du général lecointe on multiplie
les signes qui veulent montrer
l'apaisement en tous les cas entre le
président de la république et et les
armes et les ces moments là où le
général
le chef d'état major des armées le
président se retrouve en tête à tête
sont des moments quand même rare même si
c'est le dialogue et direct donc c'est
quelquefois le moment de deux d'échanger
quelques mots bref de remerciement de
remarques et autres c'est voilà c'est le
moment de dialogue dans lequel ce
dialogue se fait douce et ces petits
gestes qui avait eu
on se souvient de l'image autour de
l'arc de triophe de triomphe où tous les
chefs d'état major des armées étaient
rassemblés autour du président avec une
vue aérienne plongeante sur ce cercle
pour montrer l'unité
que certains plutôt à l'extérieur des
armes et tenter d'ébranler et voilà
cette unité cette cohésion marque forte
des armées et qui est sans doute un de
leurs biens importants donc le chef des
armées qui qui salue les chefs
d'état-major le son prochain chef d'état
major des armées avec lequel
généralement thierry burkhard voilà au
moins pour une année d'ici les élections
il aura il aura travaillé et a trouvé le
trouver le bon tempo
c'est toujours aussi une affaire
d'hommes le dans la chaîne de décision
française
il est un lien direct comme le rappelait
l'amiral contrairement à d'autres pays
ou qu'on me le rappeler nicolas barotte
contrairement à d'autres pays en france
il ya un lien direct entre le président
et le chef d'état-major des armées par
téléphone voilà cent 100 le parlement
donc avec des avantages et des
inconvénients mais voilà un parlement
qui dans les opérations et a un rôle un
peu différent donc c'est une affaire
d'hommes de ceux de se comprendre de
serbes de s'apprécier ne se respectent
et voilà on l'a vu en train de saluer le
chef d'état-major de la marine l'amiral
pierre vandier ancien pacha du charles
de gaulle et le chef d'état major de
l'amée de l'armée de l'air qui est
également sur le départ qui va partir à
l'otan le général la vigne et le
directeur général de la gendarmerie
nationale pendant que on va peut-être
avoir justement pensent-ils les images
de la fp arrête de se figer la
présentation au drapeau on va vivre ça
avant de retrouver bruno dray
[Musique]
non
à
[Musique]
ap
oh
hahaha
[Musique]
à
non
[Musique]
oh
à
la musique
roman
on
on sait comment
ans
à
or
vous parlez hockey nous sommes toujours
sur les champs elysées donc au niveau de
la rue de berri concernant les
militaires que vous voyez derrière moi
nous sommes situés entre l'armée de
l'air et la marine nationale juste là
vous verrez derrière moi sur ces images
de raphaël les règles que les militaires
ont changé de position ils sont
désormais face à la concorde prêt à
partir prêts à marcher c'était un petit
peu reculer et mis de côté pour laisser
passer le président de la république qui
a descendu les champs elysées
il ya désormais une quinzaine de minutes
et qui a passé en revue les les troupes
escortés par la garde républicaine ainsi
que les motos et qui vient juste
d'arriver à concorde vous l'avez suivi
en direct sur figaro live alors nous
sommes donc désormais prêt pour pour
attendre ce défilé qui doit démarrer
je suis entourée de public contrairement
à l'année dernière où il n'y avait pas
de public donc le public renoue avec les
militaires et l'armée aujourd'hui et je
suis d'ailleurs à côtés de giorgio
bonjour jaune
d'où venez vous à giorgio et je vais en
italie d'où en italie oudinet et
pourquoi vous êtes vous êtes là
aujourd'hui pour en france je travaille
ici depuis deux ans avec des contrôles
financière pour en banque et j'ai voulu
venir si bercy
pourquoi je veux remercier la france
pour que pourquoi j'ai reçu la deuxième
dose de lennox ans et c'était important
et vous est-ce que vous aimez l'armée
les militaires est ce que vous avez une
accointance particulière avec les
militaires dans votre famille ou dans
votre passé
oui oui mon père c'est un colonel de
l'armée italienne il est toujours en
activité et donc c'était pour vous
important de venir rendre hommage aux
militaires français aujourd'hui
oui oui aussi voici pour les militaires
pour et qu'est ce que vous attendez plus
particulièrement dans ce dvd est ce
qu'il ya un corps de métier que vous
vous attendez particulièrement de
défilés ou ou un type de véhicule
ouais
me les flèches tricolores il met aussi
les
toutes les patrouilles
des policiers
[Musique]
merci merci giorgio on le rappelle qu'il
ya plusieurs plusieurs troupes qui sont
à l'honneur lors de ce défilé donc la
tasse la taxe proche du malade 0 ce
matin la taxe leur passeport spécial
chocolat qui sera envoyée du que au
sahel ainsi que la police municipale de
nice qui défilera à la toute fin du
défilé peut-être
merci brune c'est la taskforce takouba
oui effectivement on va y revenir et
merci donc à george o'dowd à voir
témoigné en direct effectivement cet
attrait qui exercent d'ailleurs le
défilé militaire sur les personnes
étrangères savait d'ailleurs
impressionné beaucoup
donald trump la première fois qu'il est
et qu'il était venu et d'ailleurs alors
qu'on va voir là la parade d'ouverture
le tableau d'ouverture pardon qui va
être présentée devant la tribune
officielle ici la place de la concorde
cette petite remarque d'un internaute
qui on nous disait que c'était un défilé
digne du soviétisme c'est vrai que cet
exercice du défilé militaire et c'est
d'ailleurs ça qui avait impressionné
trump qui avait voulu le faire
d'ailleurs par la suite une parade à
washington c'est quand même un exercice
très français pour nous c'est très très
habituel mais c'est assez c'est assez
unique
mon histoire qui date de la fête de la
fédération donc qui est l'anniversaire
de la prise de la bastille donc et qui
s'inscrit dans une longue continuité
historique et il faut qu'on il faut
comprendre sans doute les défilés et
l'exercice du défilé dans cette le temps
historique après pour répondre à
l'internaute le le défilé a tendance
aussi à évoluer donc il peut paraître un
peu figé mais l'intégration dans le
défilé de des différents corps
en uniforme que ce soit la police que ce
soit les douaniers que ça soit voilà
différentes institutions tend aussi à le
faire évoluer à ne pas être uniquement
un défilé un défilé militaire
voilà après l'exercice aussi et aussi
pour montrer que les hommes politiques
passent l'armée reste et cette garantie
de sécurité pour la défense de la france
voilà n'est pas figé n'est pas lié fort
n'est pas lié à un homme mais a lié à
quelque chose de supérieur voilà un bien
commun supérieur pour la france d'où
cette cette inscription voilà dans ce
temps long historique et on en parle et
voilà de l'intégration de ces de ces
différents corps et aussi vient venir
avec ce tableau intitulé voilà concours
national qui vient rappeler des qui
vient essayer de représenter des années
des mois difficiles et puis se projeter
dans l'avenir en espérant un avenir plus
radieux avec la devant sur les images de
deux unités donc la fanfare de la garde
républicaine
et puis derrière une petite
particularité c'est la fanfare du 2e
régiment de hussards une unité de
renseignement de l'armée terre qu'on
verra on verra certains représentants
des filets et ce qui est particulier
c'est que c'est ces musiciens ce sont
des réservistes sont soit des
réservistes
soit des volontaires des civils
volontaires qui viennent participer
maîtres qui viennent participer aux
cérémonies et viennent avec la musique
qui vient aussi rythmé ces cérémonies
apporter leurs compétences donc des
hussards et 12e tenu un peu à peu
différente voilà une star à droite avec
avec le ton bleu et marron et des
hussards parachutistes
à gauche on les voit plus bleu et rouge
donc ce cas c'est assez intéressant à la
cds se sont se sont ce sont des civils
qui viennent qui viennent venir dans qui
viennent danser fanfare participer voilà
là aussi montré que cette unité de la
nation
du plus grand nombre le côté dit défilé
has been du 14 juillet peut-être que là
une des réponses c'est de voir aussi
l'engouement populaire les personnes qui
le regarde qui le nombre de personnes de
téléspectateurs d'auditeurs qui sont là
sa marque encore c'est une année par an
un signe sans doute d'attachement voilà
ce qui nous protège ce finalement ils
sont pour les armes et ses 300 milles
sur une grande population ils sont quand
ils sont pas nombreux donc c'est un peu
un jour particulier où ils sont cette
spécificité militaire de prendre et de
prendre la vie est risqué de la perdre
voilà une mise en avant sur sur une
journée un peu pour eux pascal nous
demande si les jeunes étaient venus pour
pour protester et ne devait pas venir on
regardera ça justement s'il n'y a pas
des des tentatives
après le défilé c'est ce qu'on avait vu
en 2010 9
pour l'instant rien n'a été signalé et
le passage des malades macron haut
niveau
de là où se trouvait l'équipe de finir
en live ou une d'audrey et raphaël
lazrag s'est passée dans dans le calme
devrait reposer la question justement à
l'amiral coldefy sur le caractère un peu
spécifique du du défilé c'est vrai que
c'est quelque chose que l'on ne voit pas
tellement dans les autres grandes
démocraties
wii fit mouche appui à la culture à
londres vous avez des parades pour la
reine qui sont de la même nature
en allemagne une soirée aux flambeaux de
la bundeswehr devant la porte de
brandebourg sert aussi beaucoup de
gueule rien à voir avec les députés
communistes la danse quand on parlait
donc c'est l'expression de la nation et
comme l'indiquent très bien florian
tient victor dans les parties d'une
manifestation purement militaire avec
maintenant une manifestation qui
rassemble l'ensemble des acteurs de la
vie de la vie publique française
donc c'est plutôt l'expression de la
nation qui se retrouvent dans cette
journée bien sûr avec une colonne
vertébrale militaire mais pour moi ça me
semble les évolutions qu'il est très
représentatif de l'évolution de notre
société où finalement tout le monde vit
avec tout le monde et guillaume
important de le manifester en public
je crois que les franciscains déçu si le
fait en juillet donc on a rappelé
l'origine elle fait de la fédération est
été supprimés ou prenez une autre
tournure mais on sait faire de grands
événements sur le temps et didier le
bicentenaire de la révolution avec
jean-michel good on a vu des avis des
choses aussi l'ex-première donc aller au
delà de cette manifestation globale de
citoyenneté france france réunis autour
de son armée et des acteurs de la vie
publique une
une autre intervention à l'instant de
christian nous dit qu'il a déjà vu outre
laissé à monique les parades que vous
signalez tout à l'heure amiral une belle
cérémonie aussi et celle des onze gardes
à edimbourg en présence de la reine
il l'a vu il a admiré pascal nous
remercient
2 du fait que l'on lise ces questions
alors juste une chose on évite les
insultes on évite les grossièretés
on est là pour des maps même revenir sur
les questions sensibles n'y a aucun
tabou
on revient sur tous les sujets et tous
les sujets d'actualité qui ont marqué
les questions militaires les questions
stratégiques et les rapports entre armée
et nation à des questions politiques et
ça me permet de re de rebondir sur ce
que dit pierre qui nous reprochent de ne
pas nous a préparés pour commenter ce
défilé alors pierre je vous fais de deux
choses la première c'est que justement
on essaye de ne pas que de ne pas vous
raconter ce que vous êtes en train de
voir puisque vous avez pas besoin de
nous pour voir ce que et vivre les
instants que nous sommes en train en
train de vivre ont fait appel à votre
intelligence et la deuxième chose c'est
que justement on est là pour répondre à
toutes vos questions
et rassurez-vous l'amiral col de fille
qui a une longue carrière militaire
longue carrière dans le haut
commandement et dans les questions
stratégiques sera à même de répondre à
toutes vos questions et de répondre même
à vos questions les plus précises tout
comme la des meilleurs spécialistes de
la question florent de saint victor et
vous pouvez même aller sur son blog mars
attacks et vous allez voir combien
vous aurez des réponses à toutes les
questions que vous vous posez même
celles que vous pouvez pas et notamment
cette infos inédites sur ce qu'ont fait
les forces spéciales en afghanistan en
tous les cas je vous lance le défi vous
restez avec nous et puis on regarde si
effectivement on a pu répondre à vos
questions ou si on n'a pas pu bien se
préparer à commenter ce défi d alors
10h39 normalement devrait commencer on
est un petit peu en retard
le défilé des avions peut-être un
commentaire sur ce que encore on est en
train de voir cette parade d'ouverture 7
ce tableau d'ouverture pardon le but
c'est de célébrer la sortie de la
pandémie
on s'avance pas un peu quand même
surtout après les annonces du produit
c'est d'essayer de se projeter dans un
avenir plus brillant avec cet ensemble
de trompettes et et de tambours des
différents temps forts et de désarmer
ses voiles à cette volonté là on voit le
les trompettes du 1er rhp régiment de
hussards parachutistes août à gauche en
bleu une unité de cavalerie de l'armée
de terre on voyait tout à l'heure le 2e
régiment de hussards
voilà c'est mettre un peu de un peu de
joie et un peu de peps dans un
environnement et dans un
en temps un peu compliqué on verra si
les tambours et les trompettes suffisent
si cette solidarité permettra on
l'espère tous deux de tenir et de sortir
de ce marasme
je réponds à new wave aussi un qui
s'interroge sur le fait qu' certains des
cravates et pas des cravates justement
il y en a qui ont des uniformes des
camps des cravates sont pas des cravates
et on prend tous les gens tels qu'ils
sont aujourd'hui vous continuez à nous
nous faire justement à nous faire
partager vos commentaires new wave ou
dit encore des avions il aurait pu faire
défiler des bateaux pour changer c'est
vrai que moi un jour on aimerait bien
avoir une belle parade navale mais bien
sur scène à paris ce sera difficile ça
se fait ça s'est déjà fait il ya
quelques années à toulon donc un peu
décorrélé du 14 juillet mais il ya eu
des grandes parades présidentielle au
large de toulon avec des bateaux ou la
marine la marine a mises en oeuvre ces
différents bâtiments c'est comme
aujourd'hui l'armée de l'air et de
l'espace on verra pas des satellites des
filets pourtant ils sont bien présents
il va sur les communications pour le
défilé aérien
donc on essaye lors du défilé il essaye
de représenter autant que possible la
diversité des unités des équipements et
autres mais il est sans doute plus il
est sans doute plus simple
voilà pour les avions et les troupes à
pied et motorisées de les représenter
mais voilà les grandes parades
présidentielle navale ça existe et le
monde de son président sarkozy il y en a
une par exemple c'est vrai que ça fait
quelques temps que ça n'a pas été fait
mais ça c'est les frégates sur le
pont-neuf je suis pas sûr que ça passe
nous dit entendeur je pense que l'amiral
col de fille pourra nous le confie nous
le confirmer il y à une question
également qui est posée par pascal et
voilà on voit on va voir revivre
justement le passage de la patrouille de
france début du défilé aérien avec
beaucoup d'incertitudes du fait de la
météo ces derniers jours pour savoir si
le créneau sera 10 sera sera possible
donc des avions qui volent à à 300
mètres d'altitude donc avec un plafond
nuageux qui étaient parfois menaçant
donc les voix des grandes interrogations
les métérologues désarmés ont été
beaucoup sollicités ces derniers jours
pour voir si ça passait et donc ça passe
parce que voilà pour des questions de
sécurité pour il y avait des
interrogations mais là la patrouille de
france
les fumigènes dans le bonheur de son
passé voilà passage réussi pour la
patrouille de france qui est arrivé
certaines années que il ya
certes un fumigène qui puisse l'être
voilà voilà les erreurs des petites
erreurs là aussi non du fait de la météo
en 2010 par exemple et le défilé aérien
avait été un peu tronqué avec des avions
qui n'avait pas décollé qui n'avait pas
été inséré dans ses boxes parce que
c'est plus plus la météo est peu plus
compliqué plus l'exercice est délicat
comme les avions sont entre cinq et dix
mètres se voit les alphajet vol à cinq
mètres les uns des autres les gros
avions sont à une dizaine de mètres
donc avec beaucoup de vent beaucoup de
turbulences
la sécurité elle était un peu con
premier donc les années passées il ya eu
des adaptations du clan on voit les les
boks qui vont défiler les uns après les
autres
pour ce défilé aérien d'aidé voilure des
voilure fixe avec voilà les avions de
transport avec des cases à un casa qui
ont 30 d'arrivée j'ai l'image de
planètes plus parfois difficile à suivre
dès des boks qui veulent représenter un
peu les différentes capacités de l'armée
de l'air cette capacité à se projeter
vite à se projeter loin notamment avec
des ravitailleurs donc celle là on voit
mieux les images ce n'est pas un casa
donc c'est un transall le transall sam
qui vient symboliser ici les 30 ans de
l'opération daguet donc lors de la
reprise de l'irak en 1991 la guerre la
guerre durant la guerre 1991 la guerre
du golfe trente ans avec un transall
vénérable qui va sans doute passer un de
ses derniers défilés au dessus des
champs et qui va bientôt quitter le
service en 2022 la majorité des transall
ne le quitteront le quitteront le
quitteront les rangs de l'armée de l'air
et ce qui est intéressant c'est voilà
l'opération daguet ya trente ans mais
c'est aussi un peu symbolique de ces
opérations que constaterait que les
armes et s'apprête peut-être à revivre
des opérations de autant son intensité
face à des adversaires équivalente ou
quasi-équivalents qui change des
récentes opérations face à des guérillas
où les des insurrections peut-être -
développer technologiquement
alors est-ce que c'est ce sont les
avions qui sont censés représenter la
sécurité civile que l'on annonce alors
là c'est les des mirages on voit les
mirages donc la capacité de l'armée de
l'air à agir dans la profondeur ses
manières brisé l'espoir il t'a fait
aller loin et vite
peut-être que les images d'avant on les
voyait avec des avions plus gros des
ravitailleurs ou développer des avions
radar des awacs qui sont capables de
contrôler et d'avoir une situation
aérienne complète
à vrai dire je pense que certains avions
n'ont pas participé au défilé
peut-être du fait justement de la météo
comme ça par raccord avec qui était ce
qui était complètement avancé voilà des
mirages des mirages devant des rafales
derrière cette capacité douala de le la
de de l'armée de l'air à mixer les
différents appareils pour des frappes
pour de la défense anti aérienne et à
permettre aux chefs militaires
différentes options la voilà des rafales
et donc c'est ça il manque
il manque certains appareils qui n'ont
pas qu'ils n'ont pas du fait des
conditions qui n'ont pas si donc pas
participé au défilé donc voilà ça
restera au moins pour le défilé aérien
un défilé aérien particulier qui
rentrera dans l'histoire
néanmoins malgré les conditions les
opérations et la guerre ne s'arrête pas
donc aussi l'armée de l'air est capable
de faire voler là c'est la partie des
forces aériennes stratégiques donc la
dissuasion nucléaire donc on devrait
voir un box d'appareils constitué
uniquement de rafale maintenant gris sur
gris le camouflage fonctionne et il est
parfois un peu compliqué de repérer et
de décrypter on a parlé voilà on à l'onu
voilà on voit les rafales les bidons les
bidons qui sont sous les avions qui
permettent de garder deux gagnants en
allonge voilà donc là typiquement un
ravitailleur devait les accompagnait
vous ravitailleur l'a330 mrtt le phoenix
chi li ser transmettre des tonnes et des
tonnes de carburant en l'air laon tandis
qu'on voit apparaître au dessus de l'arc
de triomphe la partie aéronaval je faire
à l'avenir alcool défi ça a un peu
évolué depuis son époque avec tout le
respect que j'ai pour lui et voilà donc
les rafales qui sont arrivés qui
remplaçait les super étendard les les
appareils hawk eye avec leurs radars au
dessus lors la partie ronde qui tourne
qui permet d'avoir cette situation est
donc là les rafales version marine cross
sorti la crosse d'appontage qui servent
à rattraper les brins d'arrêt sur les
sur les porte avions à l'atterrissage on
les voit bien ils sont bien sortis les
marins du groupe aérien embarqué qui
viennent de passer derrière les avions
de patrouille maritime qui s'occupe
notamment de la chasse et de la lutte
anti sous marine avec des falcons
derrière pour la surveillance maritime
surveiller avec plein de capteurs des
avions bardée de capteurs de radars qui
sont capables de faire de l'imagerie du
recueil de signaux électroniques et qui
permettent
voilà d'assurer cette surveillance des
approches maritimes françaises et puis
derrière plus imposants les avions de
transport de l'armée de l'air en tête
avec ses quatre moteurs vous allez la
fameuse à 400 qu'il est tant d'encre
voilà qui qu'il faut jure à voler tout à
fait et qui monte en puissance qui les
défauts les longs défauts de jeunesse
sont en train d'être petit à petit
réparer on rappelle peut-être que
c'était la polémique autour de la
création de cet avion c'est que c'est un
agent qui a été voulu par plusieurs pays
qu'il a été très difficile pour tous les
pays de se mettre d'accord et donc ça a
pris énormément de temps ça a pris
énormément d'argent
à tel point qu'à un moment on a plus cru
que ces avion volerait dans les airs et
qui verrait le jour tout à fait là qui
aujourd'hui montrent toutes ses
capacités à que plus en plus de capacité
à envoyer sa balance beaucoup en l'air
il doit avoir beaucoup de vent les
pilotes avaient du mal à garder lax et
tandis que c'est le début commence voilà
le défilé après défilé à pied avec la
force takouba tout à fait on va on va
peut-être florent peut-être d'ailleurs
souligné qu' il y avait notamment un hub
un ensemble
de la sécurité civile qu'il veut voler
il me semble qu'on ne l'a pas vu
peut-être que c'était dû justement de la
météo la condition météo ainsi que des
moyens d'essais de la dg a donc la
direction générale de l'armement c'est
une entité importante au sein des
désormais celle qui vraiment prépare
l'avenir gagner l'avenir le thème du
défilé prépare l'avenir sur les plans
des matériels est donc cette direction
générale de l'armement du ministère des
armées a des moyens d'essais donc des
avions des hélicoptères là il devait
avoir notamment un avion un peu
particulier c'est un mirage avec un des
deux rafale pour tester les radars des
rafales donc un banc d'essai qui sert à
tester les nouveaux radars donc ils vont
bien
ils ont coupé un bout et émis sur le mr
un mirage refaire un arrêt aux stands et
prendre un peu de hauteur si je puis
dire puisqu'on devait avoir le défilé
aérien
et ce qui est intéressant mais l'alcool
de file dans ce que souligné florent de
saint victor c'est qu'on voit quand même
que souvent les moyens aériens peuvent
servir justement à à la marine
quelle est l'expérience que vous avez et
sur quoi justement vous avez travaillé
quand vous étiez notamment l état major
sur ces questions d'abord effectivement
j'ai commandé un porte avions est une
force aéronavale et j'ai été j'ai été
assez impliqué dans l'emploi de ces
forces aéronautiques navals elles datent
pas d'hier elle a plus de sens tant
qu'homme comme en angleterre comme aux
états unis
et c'est là c'est la composante aérienne
troisième dimension des forces de
surface
elle représente en gros un quart des
encarts et un cinquième des capacités de
de l'armée de l'air et c'est un
complément les avions et les avions sur
les mêmes actuellement avec le rafale
donc c'est exactement la même chose
je voulais simplement indiqué sur les
avions de patrouille maritime sont les
avions les plus compliqués au monde car
non seulement ils font de la la chasse
aux sous marins avec des bouées des
intercepteurs des torpilles mais
également ils bombardent à terre comme
ils le font en irak ils servent de
pêcher volant comme ils l'ont fait
rochât au sahel
ce sont les avions qui sont de
véritables frégate frégate en l'air qui
qui sont effectivement onéreux compliqué
mais sur lesquelles on ne pourrait faire
partir de sous-marins en toute
tranquillité et on pourrait opérer un
peu partout donc l'expérience qu'on a
c'est que c'est une j'allais dire c'est
un un outil complémentaire et grâce au
porte avions qui peut se déplacer a pas
besoin de papillons d'escale pas besoin
de ravitailleurs tiens on tient dans la
durée des semaines et des semaines de de
déploiement en étant capable de frapper
tous les jours et avec le couple rafale
charles de gaulle
on a vraiment des capacités très très
important n'empêche pas que dans ma
démonstration qui a fait l'armée de
l'air de se projeter à 20000 km avec 3
ravitailleurs et deux appels 100 m il
est important de montrer qu'on pouvait
aller loin mais j'allais dire le corps
de bataille c'est le porte-avions qu'il
représente parce qu'il peut rester trois
mois dans le coin on se rappelle tous
les jours ça c'est le saas et le point
important mais on se complète et et la
dimension aérienne en france c'est
l'armée de l'air marine importe son
complément la marine on la verra mais
elle fait le métier
les trois autres comme la gendarmerie
nationale effet 30% ses activités dans
l'action publique de l'état en mer
pollution sauvetage drogue etc
elle fait le métier de l'infanterie
parachutistes avec des spéciales elle
fait les métiers de l'armée de l'air
avec des rafales d des pâtes marée des
et des hélicoptères et le fait bien sûr
le métier de marin avec les régates télé
et les sous-marins donc chacune de ses
composantes pour nous alors là c'est le
marin qui parle est essentielle à une
plus importante que l'autre on voit
moins les bateaux comme vous l'avez dit
des rebuts nabavi y en a eu de mémoire
en 76 avec giscard en 94 avec mitterrand
et je n'avais plus la date avec sarkozy
c'est une fois tous les dix quinze ans
ça suffit largement
il en joue je vous coupe 30 secondes
pour dire que la force la taskforce
takouba on vient de voir justement vient
d'ouvrir la partie donc à pied du défilé
on va revenir peut-être sur les
justement l'apport de la marine est ce
que vous dites est assez important je
reviens quand vous employer l'expression
de pc volant c'est leur poste de
commandement volant peut-être on ré
insistera sur cet aspect là avec vous à
miral est avec vous florent sur le fait
que les véhicules les que ce soit les
bateaux que ce soit les avions ne sont
pas toujours que des instruments pour
faire la guerre directement pour tirer
mais également des lieux qui peuvent
servir de commandement et de et d'état
major pour les différentes opérations
on voit actuellement donc la partie du
défilé qui concerne les écoles préparer
l'avenir puisque c'est le thème de ce
défilé est bien c'est d'abord former
tous et tousser
ah mais toutes ces femmes qui vont
servir dans les armées dans la défense
dans la protection et le service du
territoire et avec notamment là la
fameuse devise de saint cyr ils
s'instruisent pour vaincre mais là c'est
l'école polytechnique florent talent est
traditionnellement l'école politique ni
qui ouvre le défilé des troupes à pied
on voit le command car de du général
adjoint engagement qui s'occupe des
opérations dans la zone de défense
la zone qui est sous la responsabilité
du gouverneur militaire de paris donc
qui commande ce défilé des troupes à
pied on le voit aux images en train de
passer puis juste derrière donc viendra
l'école l'école polytechnique l'école de
formation
de d'excellence des scientifiques qui
partent notamment au sein des armées
ils partent aussi dans les entreprises
civiles
voilà qui ouvre le défilé polytechnique
amiral col de fille c'est là aussi
quelques quelques changements maintenant
l'école et est fondu dans un ensemble ça
fait longtemps qu'elle a quitté la
montagne sainte geneviève à paris pour
se retrouver à saclay oui les fondus
dans un ensemble avec de grandes écoles
d'ingénieurs ça s'appelle l'institut
polytechnique de paris p paris qui doit
voir deux ans d'existence et qui permet
de j'allais dire de montrer l'ensemble
de capacité à avoir des universitaires
de haut niveau dans les sciences et de
nous faire entrer dans le classement
mondial que que l'on fait des
différentes universités mais bien sûr
garde il ya les autres qui sont qui sont
partie prenante de cet institut
polytechnique
alors l'école polytechnique bien sûr il
ya des militaires ce m'amuser de vous
entendre parler des tableurs excel il ya
là deux mille polytechnicien la dg a et
tous les officiers de marine sur
ingénieur diplômé d'état les officiers
de l'armée les rocci donc que ta ble
retirer pour les fantassins amiral qu'on
disait sa fondation scientifique aussi
c'était juste une petite revanche une
petite remarque au passage donc l'x ne
fournit plus de gros contingents pour
les armées mais également mais a
toujours un contingent solide
l'espé partie des grands corps à la
sortie d' la sortie de polytechnique
pour deux c'est essentiel et on voit
l'école de gendarmerie
des officiers de gendarmerie de melun
qui est en train de défiler de passer
qui donc former les officiers les
officiers qui sur titre ou les
sous-officiers qui passe officiers sont
informés à hamelin dans des promotions
qui sont généralement commune donc voilà
les sous contrairement à saint cyr où on
verra on verra ça juste après les
sous-officiers passant officiers et aux
nouveaux officiers sont formés ensemble
hamelin question d'artemis on a vu tout
à l'heure la force 4 takouba passé est
ce qu'un symbole voulue par emmanuel
macron de faire défiler en premier la
force des coups bas pour mettre en avant
la coopération européenne amiral col de
fille c'était c'était un des sens il me
semble effectivement voulu par le
président de la république alors qu'on
voit les élèves officiers de l'école de
saint cyr des filets d'un grand message
politique en faisant défiler takouba
dents au sein desquels d'ailleurs je
voulais mentionner le fait que des
suédois les suédois sont avec nous
depuis depuis toujours et depuis vous
citiez artemis et que c'est le nom d'une
opération qui s'est passé au congo en
2003 les forces spéciales c'est d'oise
était avec nous donc il est important
dans le débat que le président bak rond
a lancé vers nos partenaires européens
de montrer que les soldats qui étaient
avec nous dans la tendance et de force à
kouba ils sont à l'honneur sur les
champs-elysées ils représentent leur
pays et pays au lieu d'être d'être fiers
si ça peut servir d'exemple tant mieux
c'est donc le 1er 3ème bataillon de
saint cyr qui est entré le 1er bataillon
de frags la dernière année des officiers
des élèves officiers qui qui qui
défilent sur sur les champs actuellement
avec une petite spécialité c'était une
école militaire des aspirants de
coëtquidan qui va arriver juste après on
va les voir à l'image les mac donc
dans le cadre de la refondation des
écoles les écoles de coëtquidan qu'il
vient académie de l'académie de saint
cyr coëtquidan à l'académie militaire
voilà trois écoles les syriens mais
saint cyrien là le m il ya l'école
militaire interarmes qui qui instruit
des officiers provost qui était
auparavant sous-officiers militaires du
rang et qui au dans la cadre de leur
l'escalier social les armées ont réussi
et passer un concours et ont réussi
brillamment et deviennent officiers et
derrière les mac école militaire des
aspirantes coëtquidan qui forment et
instruit les officiers de réserve ainsi
que les officiers sous contrat et avec
la nouvelle uniforme on le verra juste
après un uniforme bleu terre de france
qui vient d'être qui vient d'être
qui vient d'être présentée il ya
quelques jours de ça derrière donc
justement ces officiers de l'école
militaire interarmes donc voilà il est
écrit dans voilà le ver horizon la
couleur phare des premières années de la
première guerre mondiale et s'inscrire
dans une longue tradition de deux
d'officiers sous contrat qui se sont
battus pour les armes de la france
première fois sur un défilé ces
uniformes
on va rester sur ce fut là effectivement
donc vous regardez donc ces nouveaux
officiers l'école militaire donc des
aspirantes coëtquidan et la promotion du
sous lieutenant maurice genevoix avec la
devise de cette école est une vieille
denis vise qu'on retrouve souvent dans
les françaises honneur et patrie
[Musique]
et derrière une école qui va être cher
qui est cher à l'amiral col de filles il
ya été emmené au centre
il rentrait en 1965 si mes informations
sont bonnes qui est l'école navale
amiral c'est une école qui est basée
elle à brest est basé à lanvéoc poulmic
aux fourneaux fond de la rade de brest a
été basée à brest avant la guerre mais
elle a été reconstruite uniquement parce
qu'il y avait un grand plan d'eau parce
que vous savez qu'on est également à il
y avait des hydravions et puis il ya une
base aéronautique qui permet de recevoir
les rudiments de fanta siens comme j'ai
dit de pilotage d'avion très simple et
bien sûr la formation maritime
là c'est un grand campus qui est ouvert
en presqu'île de crozon large de en face
de brest alors les effectifs sont
réduits par rapport aux autres armées et
vous voyez vous voyez des officiers
étrangers parmi les instructeurs
je les vois oui on ne voit pas très bien
tous les manuels et les britanniques les
espagnols et les britanniques nous dit
florent de saint victor
après vienne à première vue on voit avec
mes genoux derrière une autre école
d'officiers l'école déficit de l'autre
armée l'armée de l'air et de l'espace
c'est l'école de l'air de salon de
provence a fait l'école de l'air
quelques semaines elle aussi en école de
l'air et de l'espace avec un changement
de son logo
l'épervier de symboles de l'armée de
l'air qui aujourd'hui un peu plus tourné
vers l'espace pour montrer ce nouveau
champ de confiture alité l'espace est
pleinement prises en compte par l'armée
de l'air qui est responsable des
opérations spatiales dans ce milieu qui
est aujourd'hui de plus en plus
important pour des questions
d'observation pour des questions de
communication avec des opérations des
adversaires qui venait perturber
les satellites français les satellites
alliés et donc une obligation une
nécessité d'en faire un milieu bien pris
en compte
derrière aussi une nouveauté l'instar
bretagne est une première pour eux de
défiler mais l'école nationale
supérieure des techniques avancées donc
bretagne donc elle aussi située à brest
des ingénieurs spécialisés notamment en
technique navale qui viendront compléter
notamment la dg a dont parlait tout à
l'heure et d'autres d'autres corps et
d'autres entités privées
voilà une formation de haut niveau pour
ses ingénieurs de l'état bretagne dont
c'est une preuve dont c'est la première
sur les champs-elysées et derrière donc
l'école de commissaires des des
commissaires de l'armée et qui va être
suivie également d'une école qui est
très importante aujourd'hui dans le
contexte de la pandémie
l'école du service de santé des armées
avant de voir justement ces écoles
défilé peut-être une question qui vous
destinez amiral une question qui est
posée par un internaute du figaro qui
s'appelle charlie que pense l'amiral
cold fish des tergiversations autour de
l'hommage au général français charles
etienne gudin ou aux gens pensent pas
grand chose parce que ça fait partie de
ces dossiers pas de deux mondes aborder
toutes les questions sensibles voyeur le
nom du jeu je trouve un peu ridicule de
de décider de faire quelque chose de
avec même la présidence de poutine à
paris et puis d'annuler au dernier
moment on a fait ça pour rester en lice
alors que les anglais étaient trafalgar
des parties du ridicule et du ridicule
qui est j'avais dire pour être hors est
clair c'est que les communicants qui
sont pas très bons dans cette affaire et
mènent les politiques dans le mur vous
pensez que il était important de faire
une cérémonie pour l'accueil du
de la dépouille de cet officier de ce
général de mort en russie pendant
pendant la campagne de russie aux côtés
de napoléon non moi pas du tout
personnellement pas du tout si on
voulait en faire un geste politique
était un geste afin de rapprochement
franco russe oui et c'était l'idée
initiale l'idée de faire une cérémonie
pour ce général brand dans la retrouver
les restes mois pour moi ça me choque
pas vraiment une grande importance à je
n'étais pas tout à fait d'accord là
dessus et ça c'est mon avis de citoyen
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu on vient
de voir donc l'école de santé des armées
et de santé à désarmer avec 11.1
souligner ses médecins dans les deux ans
qui suivent la fin de leur formation 80%
sont partis en opération oui ils servent
aussi dans les hôpitaux d'instruction
des les hôpitaux militaires les hôpitaux
d'instruction des armées mais aussi ils
sont projetés avec est projeté souvent
et très rapidement après la fin de leur
formation ils sont plongés dans dans le
grand dans des opérations une nouvelle
école de gendarmerie celle des
sous-officiers de la gendarmerie c'est
l'école de châteaulin châteaudun et
châteaulin tout à fait l'école des
sous-officiers donc la halle avec
l'école
200 l'école de santé des armées ont
conclu l'on termine les écoles
d'officiers pour passer au centre de
formation et l'école des sous-officiers
des armées et donc nous verrons dans le
même entre gendarmerie remet terre allez
on va donner satisfaction à cet
internaute qui nous demande s'il est
possible de faire taire les journalistes
pour qu'on puisse entendre la musique y
admirer de troupes alors après vous avez
les comptes facebook des armées à qui
vous retransmettent en flux réels et en
flux sans commentaire mais on va bien
entendu on n'est pas là pour vous
embêter mais pour vous informer alors on
va vivre un peu en direct ces images et
on va revenir ensuite les commenter pour
pouvoir justement mieux les vivre mieux
les comprendre
là
[Musique]
et
à
ans
[Musique]
mais
oh
il
[Musique]
à
on vient de voir passer l'école de
formation des sous-officiers de l'armée
de l'air et de l'espace vous voyez des
uniformes assez bigarrée dans le dernier
carré qui vient de passer parce que
cette école de formation forme à la fois
les sous-officiers du secteur
aéronautique globale de l'armée de l'air
et l'espace mais aussi de l'armée de
terre notamment pour les hélicoptères
envoyés le béret bleu de l'aviation
légère de l'armée de terre notamment à
la fin la latte l'école des mousses une
école importante pour la marine donc des
les mousses les jeunes de la marine
généralement moins de 18 ans qui sont
qui sont formés et dont une très grande
partie par après c'est un contrat au
sein de la marine nationale
on a vu je salue arnaud qui viennent
nous rejoindre également sur le chat du
figaro et qui viennent nous rejoindre
également en train de nous nos de
regardez bien vous commentez on attend
vos questions vos commentaires je
rajoute également sur les commentaires
la règle c'est que vous toutes les
opinions sont bientôt entendue
entendable respectable et bienvenus les
commentaires les questions mais pas d'
insulte et pas de pas de pas de
grossièretés et bien sûr on respecte les
règles de la modération dans le cadre de
la défense la dignité des personnes et
tout
toutes remarques qui contrevient à sa et
banny est modérée et je vous demande de
le respecter
nous prenons toutes les opinions des uns
et des autres et nous les respectons et
donc merci de respecter les règles
élémentaires de modération une une
question qui est posée justement par au
minium et on va revenir d'ailleurs sur
le service de santé des armées avec
l'amiral la mer alcool de figue
est-ce que l'armée est vacciné juste une
réponse sur saint florent a priori il
n'y avait pas d'obligation vaccinale nom
ne peut pas partir en opérations
extérieures sans être vaccinés dernières
nouvelles c'est est complète des armées
il n'oublie donc notamment le service de
santé des armées qui étaient en première
ligne pour la vaccination des militaires
dans le cadre des opérations extérieures
les militaires reçoivent déjà un certain
nombre de vaccins obligatoires contre
notamment les maladies tropicales et
autres maladies rares de ce genre donc
ils ont déjà
un des vaccins à jour et le vaccin anti
qu'ovide avait s'ajouter à ces vaccins
et donc depuis quelques mois les
militaires partent en opération sur les
bateaux pour les navires ou pour l'armée
de l'air étaient vaccinés est
effectivement vos quito nous dit
emmanuel macron n'a pas obliger les
policiers à se vacciner et c'est vrai
c'est une des polémiques justement suite
à ces annonces à venir à l'école de
filles justement on parlait du service
de santé des armées
c'est un service qui est important et
qui est remontée en puissance si on peut
dire avec la crise épidémique
alors que l'on voit
les éléments de la gendarmerie nationale
suivie de la légion étrangère
la région demande marche du tchad
effectivement autant pour moi je m'en
excuse
on va y revenir pour les commenter dans
un instant juste un mot peut-être un
miracle sur le service de santé des
armées et la prépondérance sa
prépondérance depuis deux ans lors il
est capital pour les armées en opération
sommes des spécialistes de la médecine
d'urgence et notre objet de toujours de
rapatrier dans les meilleures conditions
les les blessés de façon à ce qu'il soit
traité au mieux dans nos hôpitaux
le deuxième point c'est que là aussi que
c'est la symbolique de l'uniforme les
hôpitaux il a plu beaucoup la
suppression du service militaire à paris
déjà déjà et persil déjà les maladies
tropicales ebola et persie bien sûr les
d'autres dans les grandes dans les
grands traumatismes et il est il est
frappant de voir les français sont
rassurés dès qu'ils voient des médecins
en uniforme ça c'est l'armée qui nous
protège
1 % de l'offre hospitalière française
avait que j'allais dire une dimension
symbolique et affective qui est très
important les nos armées ne pourrait pas
se déployer sans des médecins compétents
hommes et femmes bien sûr infirmiers
anesthésistes et c'est pour les oreilles
pour sauver nos blessés en opérations
extérieures froid que c'est capital
effectivement il ya eu là des moments de
restriction c'est qu'on a fermé le val
de grâce à paris
et bien sûr ça remonte en puissance
parce que dans l'opération résilience
l'opération de lutte contre le provident
le service de santé des armées est
particulièrement impliquée trente six
rondes merci beaucoup on a vu
à des gendarmes qui est des filets et
c'est l'une des spécificités
cette année c'est pour ça d'ailleurs en
réponse à un internaute pourquoi on
commente parce que justement on signale
les surprises et on signale ce qui est
justement spécifique cette année ces
gendarmes se sont ce qu'on appelle les
héros des quotidiens vous avez
d'ailleurs un très beau reportage de
syrie des stein du figaro magazine que
vous allez retrouver dans le chat qui en
a rencontré certains et c'est un bloc de
différents genres de différentes jambes
gendarmes provenant de différentes
unités ce qui a par exemple était
intervenu sur la tragédie de saint-just
il ya quelques mois dans le cou de
domaine tout à fait voilà sur d'autres
forcené sur des accidents du quotidien
donc voilà un bloc de héros du quotidien
de la gendarmerie nationale pour mettre
en avant toutes ces pertes ou ces
gendarmes qui sont intervenus dans les
opérations du quotidien au cours de la
dernière année sur les petites comme sur
les grandes voies là donc ils avaient
fait 1 c'était pas une unité constituée
voilà c'était une unité haddock
tandis qu'on voit passer après le 31e
régiment génie de valeur sarrazin
tout à fait le 68e régiment d'artillerie
d'afrique avec la ceinture en flanelle
rouge celle qui est caractéristique
caractéristiques de l'armée d'afrique
dont elle reprend les traditions
régiment d'un régiment d'artillerie
d'afrique valbonne du côté
lyon suivi du 3e régiment du matériel
lui qui on va le voir
qui lui est située sur plusieurs
plusieurs plusieurs sites
théo nous demande combien de militaires
défilent environ environ 5000
c'est ce qu'a annoncé en tout cas ce
matin nicolas barotte correspondant
défense dans le article du figaro y
présente justement les spécificités mais
c'est l'esprit de ceux de ce défilé
cette année et dans les pures des autres
défilés en effet en un an environ 5000
hommes qui défilent on outre 50 et 70
appareils
alors cette année c'est un peu
particulier parce que cause de la météo
aux lyonnais du moins mais mais voilà
cinquante à soixante dix appareils
hélico et 50 à 70 nous avions donc là
nous avons le 3e régiment du matériel un
régiment un peu particulier dont la une
des spécificités
ils sont spécialistes du pliage de
parachute de l'entretien des parachutes
la france ça fait parti des capacités
rares détenus par la france la france
maintien des compétences dans le domaine
de la mise en place via parachutes des
hommes et du matériel et le 3e rmat 3e
régiment du matériel et spécialisés
voient la danse est maintenant c'est cet
entretien des parachutes donc avec
beaucoup de pluie hier qui font un
travail de minutie et de pour lesquels
les parachutistes qui les utilisent en
toute confiance c'est eux qui sont les
gardiens de leur sécurité
voilà donc plié à la main généralement
des parachutes sur des longues tables de
pliage et juste après derrière eux une
des voies là encore une autre
spécificité de ce 14 juillet le service
militaire adapté
nous avons le service militaire de la
martinique qui le
le régiment fondateur de ceux de là
aussi cette implication des armées
auprès de la jeunesse donc chez les
ultramarins des militaires qui encadrent
et propose des formations
professionnelles à une jeunesse
relativement défavorisés est en
difficulté dans ces territoires
ultramarins et donc là nous avons ceux
de la martinique qui défilent devant
vous alors justement un miracle que
l'office est une question qui vous et
qui vous est cher
quel est le bilan de ceux de ses
services militaires adaptés et est-ce
qu'il atteint les objectifs qui sont
fixés justement de réinsérer cette
partie de la jeunesse française et en
particulier de cette jeunesse
d'outre-mer alors il a parfaitement
réussi dans les territoires outre-mer
parce qu'il est parti sur des objectifs
assez simple apprendre un métier à
prendre d'abord une petite discipline
militaire tout à fait tout à fait normal
mais apprendre un métier débouchant sur
des emplois de mécaniciens de
réparateurs d'hectares et cetera sur
dans le département où la collectivité
ou le territoire d'outre-mer concernés
là il a parfaitement atteint ses
objectifs 1 avec un investissement
financier important et direction adapté
et on l'a tellement bien réussi ses
objectifs que l'idée court depuis des
années de faire un service militaire
adapté en métropole pour tous ces jeunes
et pour qui n'ont pas d'emploi qui ont
su plus tôt en échec scolaire et qui ont
quand même envie de travailler à quelle
heure auxquels on donne à la fois le le
permis surtout aimé un métier demain
dans les mains ce n'est pas le cas des
services militaires ont formé en forme
et des combattants donc on en est là ça
peut pas être mis à l'échelle nationale
parce que là s'il faudrait des milliards
et beaucoup de personnel pour encadrer
je rappelle que le service militaire il
règne dans l'armée de terre il y avait
soixante mille 16 officiers et officiers
et neuf hôpitaux des armées consacré
uniquement à nous appeler donc la
facture est fait il est impossible à un
solde et dans les conditions actuelles
donc réussi en guyane en martinique en
guadeloupe un peu partout à la réunion
du service militaire adapté et des
tentatives pour faire la même chose en
métropole il ya déjà des jeunes des
tentatives j'ai pas le tableau complet
mais évidemment là on achoppe sur des
problèmes financiers
l'objectif faire peut-être alors dont le
service militaire volontaire peut-être
dans les initiatives en métropole oui
mais mais le service militaire adapté
vous donne véritablement un métier et en
sortant en guyane du régiment de dsm a
vous allez à cayenne et vous trouver un
emploi chez un garagiste un chauffagiste
etc etc ce qui est pas tout à fait le
cas du sbk
à pied continue avec des unités qui vous
sont chers d'ailleurs amiral puisque
c'était même si vous êtes quelqu'un qui
a beaucoup servi dans l'intervalle mais
qui a été d'ailleurs un des maîtres
d'oeuvre de la transformation
de pilotage de l'armée française avec le
développement de la terreur mais mais
justement donc des unités de la marine
on a les unités notamment d'un
sous-marin qui est le
les deux sous-marins nucléaires
d'attaqué suffren et émeraude alors
c'est fait pour leurs efforts a rappelé
que ce sont des desmans nucléaire
d'attaqué qui font pour les premiers
autour de 3000 tonnes et les deuxièmes
autour de 5,5 6000 tonnes mais dont les
équipages sont très réduits l'équipage
de très hautes qualifications il ya
soixante il ya soixante marins à bord 65
je crois exactement les 110 sur un sous
marin nucléaire lanceur d'engin donc là
on a vous avez des chefs de quart de
centrales nucléaires vous avez des
électrotechnicien vous avez aidé les
plantations qui ont l'habitude de
défiler jusqu'au c'est un exploit de les
faire défiler sur les champs-elysées
mais les sens très fier si ce marin
nucléaire d'attaqué
c'est clair dans le monde seuls les
membres permanents du conseil de
sécurité en ce temps-là nucléaires
lanceurs d'engins sous marin nucléaire
d'attaqué et porte-avions et ça c'est
qu'il fait la différence avec avec
d'autres marines bien sûr tout le monde
a des frégates et cetera et cetera
mais les outils qui font qu'un pays est
membre permanent du conseil de sécurité
et une dimension stratégique plus élevé
ils sont dans la marine un supporter
avions sous marins nucléaires lanceurs
d'engins et sous marins nucléaires de
tat ils font des missions dans le monde
entier peuvent rester de longues
périodes sous l'osm et ils peuvent lui
-d
bientôt les missiles de croisière parce
qu'on avait fait un petit peu de retard
vous frégate avons lancé déjà mais sous
marin c'est la place si freins qui va
dénoncer là on a un outil qui quittent
rouquette employés par 65 personnes et
qui doit coûter le prix d'une division
d'infanterie us ben moi je vous poster
un commentaire
commentaire financier mais c'est un peu
plus d'huile sur certains internautes
qui trouvent que des gens payent trop
d'impôts
donc si vous leur dites que un
sous-marin de 65 personnes coûte le prix
de
de plus de divisions qui comporte plus
de 1000 personnes effectivement ça va
soulever de la polémique non peut
répondre justement à ces polémiques
autour du budget des armées qui a été un
budget qui a été longtemps non pas un
parent pauvre mais qui a été taillée
alors que c'est une institution qui a
été de plus en plus sollicités avant de
revenir peut-être sur ces questions là
peut-être d'autres une autre précision
sur le sous-marin émeraude
c'est qu'il a passées notamment cinq
mois en mer de chine et que d'après ce
que disent qu'ils veulent nicolas
barotte pékin n'a vraiment pas apprécié
paraît-il pour reprendre son expression
la prouesse
voilà c'est on parlait de projection de
puissance en début avec le défilé aérien
là aussi la mission de l'émeraude jusque
dans la région indo pacifique et là
aussi typique de cette voie là cette
capacité de la france
rare dans le monde à projeter loin des
instruments de puissance comme un sous
marin qui est allé proches chatouiller
les les eaux les eaux chinoises dans le
respect des conventions internationales
mais cette voix lasse est capable
capacité de la france peut déranger en
effet ceux qui ont plutôt l'habitude
d'avoir un pré carré autour d'eux et
cinq mois c'est une vraie prouesse
technique
c'est une vraie prouesse logistique avec
voilà ce qu apporte un sous-marin donc
c'est rester longtemps sous l'eau et de
manière discrète
c'est passionnant les sous marins on en
sait trés on en sait très peu sur ces
outils
effectivement il y en a plusieurs
attaques on va y revenir christian les
rangs puisque vous nous faites ce
commentaire mais surtout là on voit une
unité celle du commandement de l'espace
qui est une création récente soit tout à
fait alors là les 7 vents c'est la base
aérienne 118 de mont-de-marsan mais
arrive juste après derrière qui elle
c'est l'armée de l'air la protection de
l'espace aérien français une capacité de
projection depuis les bases aériennes
françaises l'armée de l'air c'est cette
capacité à frapper fort et loin aussi
depuis leur base et le commandement de
l'espace
qui qui défilait donc et notamment deux
unités qui sont en charge à la fois de
la surveillance les objets spatiaux
avoir une connaissance de la la
situation spatiale pour éviter les pour
éviter que plusieurs satellites se
rencontrent les débris spatiaux et une
unité qui s'occupe du traitement des
images spatiales donc la france reçoit
environ 500 images spatiales par jour il
faut les traiter les diffuser les
stocker et donc c'était deux unités qui
était juste avant celle qu'on voit ici
là qui était qui sont en charge de ces
missions là c'est une un quart est aussi
pour une mission dédiée donc la mission
de ce qui rehausse expliqué alors il ya
quelques mois l'armée de l'air à
projeter loin une capacité pour faire le
tour de ses partenaires de premier rang
donc au premier rang de laquelle la
grèce l'inde et les émirats arabes unis
donc ils ont fait une tournée dans ces
pays avec des ravitailleurs des avions
pour montrer leur capacité à aller
s'entraîner à aller soutenir et vida es
vite éventuellement des alliés avec une
idée aussi de promotion comme on notera
que grèce un des émirs arabes unis sont
trois pays qui ont acheté des rafale ces
derniers temps défiler en tenue
camouflée oui ces particularités alors
là c'est aussi de ce défilé c'est le
service de commissariats en opération
donc ils rentrent tous de l'opération de
barques à naucelle il ya quelques jours
ce sont les petites mains sans qui rien
ne serait aussi possible ceux qui
s'occupent de l'habillement ceux qui
s'occupent des achats ceux qui
s'occupent des finances ceux qui
s'occupent d'eux en partie de la
logistique donc plein de services avec
un fort impact et qui permettent aux
combattants déployés en opérations
c'est pour ça que on voit qu'ils n'ont
pas tous la même quoi enfin certains ont
des bérets amarres en d'autres mains des
bernois des bérets bleus et certains ont
des casquettes d'autres des képis
c'est le signe donc 2
deux sets cette unité vingt sept unités
plus tard mais le commissariat des
armées à vannes l'a senti vraiment la
vie serait plus compliqué derrière
arrivent aussi une première aussi pour
eux le le service inter armes et des
munitions
donc le nom parle parle de mode de
lui-même ce qui sort en charge des
dépôts de munitions en france et aussi à
l'étranger en opération donc différents
dépôts de munitions un peu à différents
endroits de la indifférent deux endroits
du territoire une petite un petit
service le service le 6 multiservices
met beaucoup d'impact
le service de santé des armées également
qu'on vient de voir qui est donc en
pointe avec les pandémies pas dans la
pandémie est ce ce qui a été souligné
cette année c'est ce qu' en tous les cas
la volonté des organisateurs et les
visées de paul nous pose une question la
france ne ferait elle pas mieux de
coopérer au niveau européen pour la
défense spatiale face au mastodonte
chinois et américains amiral col de
filles on voit juste on a vu cette
nouveauté ce commandement l'espace à
l'instant c'est une création récente
mais quelles sont véritablement les
moyens est ce qu on allait à moi en ce
qu'on a les moyens de faire cette
fameuse guerre des étoiles qui avait été
lancé dans les années 80 par le
président reagan
non on n'est pas dans la guerre des
étoiles avant je réponds sur le point
vient on coopère avec des gens qui
veulent bien coopéré donc en appeler aux
européens c'est un peut crier dans le
désert on le fait depuis 20 ans 30 ans
n'empêche qu'à quelques succès en
général sur une base bilatérale
mais cet appel aux européens fait que
d'une part regard des intérêts nationaux
des industries nationales également sur
le plus dur avec nous dans ce domaine
donc il ya peu de chances pour une
coopération européenne le deuxième point
c'est que on ambitionne pas de faire la
guerre des étoiles il se trouve que
l'espace est advenu un milieu
conflictuelle
et que nos satellites qui sont
indispensables aux communications je
vais dire à la transmission d'image à
tout un tas de choses en l'opération
sont devenus des cibles et donc il faut
être en mesure de les protéger et pour
les protéger il faut démontrer qu'on
sait détruire éventuellement ou pour
perturber des satellites adverse nous
avons les capacités technologiques de la
de le faire on fait à la base de deux
démonstrateurs le faire à base de
démonstrateurs passons les
technologiques et voulait très très vite
mais j'allais dire on est on est au
premier rang en capacité en capacités
nationales et les autres hésite un petit
peu à venir avec moi j'y crois pas du
tout personnellement à ce genre de
coopération on est dans les intérêts
stratégiques des pays et là
malheureusement sur fond de quatre
grandes guerres les intérêts nationaux
l'emportent
on vient de le voir avec les allemands
l'avaient hésita lien on avec les
espagnols bien sûr avec les anglais un
regard on n'y arrive pas sauf quand les
américains mettent une chape de plomb
sur les programmes comme l'ont fait avec
le john strike fighter le f-35 là qu'ils
ont même réussi à proposer aux suisses
voilà il ya d'autres coopérations quand
même qu'on peut voir dans l'espace
j'étais justement les images
satellitaires et vous citiez de payer
notamment l'allemagne et l'italie où
quotidiennement des images sont échangés
soit radar l'image
voilà c'est vrai que ponctuellement
voilà du sàrl des satellites dans fear
luche répond actuellement ou même en
échange en gestion de la situation
spatiale
aujourd'hui dans les centres dans le
centre à toulouse des données
proviennent de ces pays pour une copine
une image la plus fine possible
donc c'est vrai que c'est ponctuel c'est
vrai que c'est compliqué c'est vrai que
c'est c'est pas forcément de grande
coopération
mais c'est vrai que c'est un axe
d'effort avec certains amis un miracle
de filles alors on parlait de moi je
n'ai situé sur la guerre des étoiles que
telle est la question posée par an
vincent roux est clair que hausser au
niveau européen avec le centre spatial
de torrejón avec un certain nombre
d'initiatives ont fait des échanges
on a plutôt développer des capacités si
je prends les allemands là que je gagne
critiquer on a plutôt développé chez
nous des capacités autour de l'optique
de l'eau tronic et les allemands du côté
de l'observation radar ont fait des
échanges de renseignements mais là il
s'agit d'échanger des renseignements
d'observation s'agit pas de la guerre
des étoiles
là on arrive sur une base beyou
trilatérale à faire des le pasteur des
choses ensemble avec les partenaires que
j'ai indiqué tout à l'heure
il y avait aussi les belges
luxembourgeois et c'est donc dans
différents pouvoirs d'observation savait
pas de guerre des étoiles on est en
train de le défilé continue de voir
certains
des unités qui gagnent souvent à
l'applaudimètre là ce sont les bailleurs
de sapeurs pompiers de france on avait
vu tout à l'heure
les sapeurs pompiers de paris qui eu
également sont des militaires florent
donc la bspp la brigade de paris qui est
une des trois brigades de sapeurs
pompiers militaires avec la brigade des
marins pompiers de marseille et la
brigade des pompiers de leur
conversation véhicule tout à l'heure une
des nouveautés avec la légion les
pompiers ont généralement sont souvent
général sont souvent déclaré vainqueur à
l'applaudimètre et le 14e bataillon de
sapeurs pompiers de france donc des
pompiers volontaires et professionnels
donc ils ne sont pas militaires qui sont
passés juste avant là on est dans la
partie du défilé où on en parlait tout à
l'heure ce défilé évolué il ya quelques
années toutes ces unités ne défilait pas
les sapeurs-pompiers l'administration
pénitentiaire certes les douanes la
police municipale qu'on commençait à
avoir en font donc la police municipale
de nice une de ses grandes premières
aussi de 2,2 cette année on pourra noter
et ça c'est le cinquième anniversaire de
l'attentât du tafel voilà la basilique
cette année on pourra noter pour faire
le lien au sein de cette police
municipale de nice plusieurs milles
ancien militaire ils sont présents
parfois même des militaires ayant un
passé opérationnel plutôt costaud on
dira donc des anciens des forces
spéciales de l'armée de l'air de l'armée
de terre qui ont rejoint en deuxième
partie de carrière cette police
municipale qui sont intervenus lors des
attentats de de nice qui ont réussi à
mettre en oeuvre leur leurs compétences
militaires dans cette nouvelle mission
donc on verra là on a on a les douanes
mais juste derrière le carré de
policiers avec ses vétérans militaires
aussi parmi eux et on voyait tout à
l'heure également à l'antenne à l'image
pardon et à l'antenne aussi le général
christophe abattent gouverneur militaire
de paris
alors là cette fois ci pas d'impair ce
qu'on voit ce qu'on aperçoit ce sont
toujours les grands gagnants de
l'applaudimètre
ce sont derrière donc les membres de la
police municipale de nice avec pour
certains un nombre de médailles un
passionnant vous le disiez il ya
effectivement des anciens et notamment
des anciens des forces spéciales tout à
fait elle assume et qui porte le drapeau
est relativement connu dans le milieu on
dira c'est un ancien commando de l'armée
de l'air son placard comme on dit parle
pour lui c'est à dire sans plaqueur de
médailles voilà ses rangées de médailles
notamment certaines on verra peut-être
6,6 à des zooms les croix de la valeur
militaire donc vraiment la médaille
remise
normalement pour des opérations au
combat au feu voilà lui trente ans ou 35
ans d'opération l'opération de 30 en un
peu moins de 30 ans d'opération dans les
forces spéciales et qui a rejoint la la
la la police municipale de nice et qui a
plus que bien réagi lors des attentats à
nice donc une figure de ces milieux
on voit en bo1 un beau geste pour lui
que que de voir défiler et de voilà un
bel hommage
et on voit aussi à sa droite des
placards de d'anciens militaires
il ya même les anciens du 2e régiment de
hussards un autre fine une autre unité
dans une unité de renseignement qui
défilent aussi au sein de ce carré de la
la police municipale et cet après midi
jean castex présidera d'ailleurs une
cérémonie sur place à nice en hommage
aux plus de 80 morts de cet attentat du
14 juillet 2016
on voit également donc arriver la légion
étrangère on va vous commenter ça et je
répond justement à cet internaute qui
lui qu'il faut qu'on présente les unités
il ya d'autres internautes qui lui
disent que ce serait bien qu'on mette le
fasse en surimpression bien on y pensera
pour les prochaines années
je réponds à cet autre internaute qui
nous disait combien il ya de personnes
qui sont présentes
la jauge cette année est de seulement
dix mille personnes contre 25 milles et
tout à l'heure l'équipe de figaro live a
pu observer qu' il y avait un nombre
limité de personnes qui étaient autour
qui étaient autorisés à entrer autour de
300 personnes et c'est strictement
surveillés strictement contrôlé la
légion étrangère avec avec toujours une
spécificité florent sait qu'elle va
moins vite que les autres elle va moins
vite donc elle défile sur une plus
courte distance donc elle a commencé au
niveau du grand palais alors que les
autres étaient un peu au dessus du fait
d'un rythme plus lent donc y sont à 88
minutes
il arrive en dernier on voit sur les
images et des applaudissements voilà les
français non par le sang versé le sang
reçu mais par le sang versé voilà la
légion étrangère cette institution si
française avec en tête les pionniers qui
ouvre la route avec leur tablier en cuir
pour résister aux dans la tradition pour
résister aux barbelés nous qu'ils
arrivaient à l'elysée c'était une de
leur protection c'est ceux qui sont en
première ligne les pionniers
les premières pour ouvrir la route et
qui continue à ouvrir la route de ce
carré de la légion ensuite vient la
musique de la légion étrangère
on verra peut-être au milieu le chapeau
chinois
avec ses coachs cheval ne se vaut qui le
boudin le oui voilà le boudin et puis le
dernier carré pour les 100 ans du 1er
régiment étranger de cavalerie de
l'unité sur shah notamment nx dispersé
et puis bbl
cavalerie légère de la légion étrangère
anciennement orange aujourd'hui à
carpiagne sud de la france qui fête ses
100 ans cette année avec une spécificité
au sirha 100 ans et jamais aucune
dissolution ou mise en sommeil voilà son
temps entre sa création est aujourd'hui
très belle ou unités commandées
presqu'un départ commandement dans
quelques jours et qui défilent à la tête
de ces hommes qui était l'année dernière
romani
hier gérard larcher le président du
sénat a remis des décrets de
naturalisation à certains légionnaires
qui au bout d'eux un premier contrat
peuvent recevoir la nationalité
française et qui il y a eu aussi hier
des remises de médaille pour action
d'éclat lors de ce mandat en opération
l'année dernière au mali un mandat
tonique rude le plus de prises à partie
des conditions compliquées et donc
certains légionnaires qui ont été
décorée pour ses faits d'armes
la légion étrangère qui rencontrent
paraît-il
dernièrement en tout cas quelques
problèmes dans suite aux mesures qui
sont prises pour lutter contre la
pandémie et donc
comme c'est un recrutement étranger
c'est difficile d'être un jeu donc on
les observe que parfois les frontières
ont été rétablis
alors oui tout à faire la queue d'aider
les difficultés notamment lors des faux
film en stricte il noté on va répondre
je vous coupe lui-même le dit pourquoi
elle marche doucement ça c'est une
tradition
tout à fait alors c'est la blague c'est
comme elle aime bien se faire applaudir
et donc elle prend son temps
voilà donc les légionnaires l'esprit
taquin le rappellerons souvent c'est
autant en profiter c'est le cas une des
vielles c'est le calme des vieilles
troupes c'est pas besoin de se presser
on à l'histoire pour nous on a nos
opérations tournées et
il ya des traditions plus historique
mais voilà pour les anecdotes c'est là
autre question donc ses 80 il pas mieux
pourquoi il porte une barbe alors les
pionniers par porte une barbe
parce que là c'est les les anciens en
section le respect ses soins l'équipe de
pionnier c'est ce qu'ils avaient suite à
leur action ont leur autorisait en plus
en plus se raser
parce que je n'avais plus rien à prouver
parce qu'ils étaient et ce qu'ils
avaient fait et puis c'est dans les
traditions c'est le barbu c'est quand
même l'ancien c'est celui qui est
respecté et les pionniers sont
régulièrement ce qui tue en deuxième
contre un troisième contrat ceux qui ont
déjà prouvé des choses ils entretiennent
cette barbe ils sont choisis même pour
le défilé du 14 juillet il faut qu'ils
aient une barbe selon certains craignent
air bien touffue et donc ils ont ils ont
une affection particulière pour leur
pilosité et la travail de longs jours
avant le défilé est alors cet internaute
nous assure que la cadence de
déplacement est calquée sur les armes
est de l'ancien régime ville de laon
pire
bravo merci pour cette pour cette
référence et se rappelle vous si vous en
avez d'autres bien vous voulez vous nous
les donner une autre
une autre donc précision on le disait
problèmes de recrutement peut-être en ce
moment en perspective à la légion alors
des problèmes alors il notait la ces
quelques dernières semaines que le
beaucoup de restrictions avaient été
levées en espérant qu'il n'y ait pas
d'autres donc il y avait des nouveaux à
nouveau des flux qui arrivait ça allait
être compliqué comme les avait pris du
retard sur les futurs recrutements mais
ça serait ouvrez donc il pouvait
bénéficier de ces arrivées aujourd'hui
il assurait pouvoir tenir leurs
objectifs de recrutement sachant qu un
des grands défis de la légion étrangère
pour son modèle d'intégration c'est
réussir à recruter des francophones ce
qui est compliqué mais pourquoi recruter
de tous les pays du monde mais les
francophones ça reste un défi de le
convaincre
alors on revient dans les heures et
c'est le défilé des hélicoptères 24
appareils once de l'armée de terre 4 de
l'armée de l'air et de l'espace iv de la
marine nationale 3 de la gendarmerie un
de la sécurité civile et un de la
direction générale de l'armement avec on
insiste cette année florent sur
l'aviation légère de l'armée de terre
qui est mise à l'honneur à travers le
groupement tactique mais pas tout à fait
un groupement celle assemblage cohérent
de différents hélicoptères capables de
faire du français
transport de frapper l'on vient de voir
passer de caracal et de fenech donc
l'armée de l'air qui vient de passer en
ouverture pareil avec lente les
anciennes générations ceux des 30 ans de
l'opération daguet qui sont pas qu'ils
sont passés les cumuler les pumas et les
gazelles ou des hélicoptères qui petit à
petit se retire du service fut derrière
des hélicoptères qu'on appelle de
nouvelle génération ça soit des années
90 cayman des tigres sont ils sont
passés la rive ceux de la marine
nationale à la gendarmerie
là on voit la gendarmerie et le jaune et
rouge le dragon de la sécurité civile
le ce de la gendarmerie qui ont beaucoup
servi notamment dans les récentes
opérations de traque
ces derniers ces dernières semaines dans
le sud de la france pour rechercher des
fonctionner donc les hélicoptères qui
permettent de rester en l'air d'observer
de haut
les ont classés vivre et la sécurité
civile les fameux dragon qui viennent
chercher les plaisanciers imprudents ou
les skieurs des skieurs imprudent aussi
et le place maintenant au défilé des
troupes motorisées
on va aller retrouver la mire alcool de
figue justement puisque cette année on
met à l'honneur une direction qui est
peut-être moins connus mais clip
extrêmement importante pour calculer les
budgets pour calculer les bons et
devenir des armées françaises c'est la
direction générale de l'armement tout à
fait là la direction générale de l'eure
pour l'armement a pour mission de
fournir les équipements aux armées
françaises
donc elles reposent sur un corps
d'ingénieurs de l'armement au les
techniciens que j'évoquais puis un autre
corps d'ingénieurs d'études et technique
en mouvement qui sortent de l'ena apparu
de la liste à brest qu'on a vu défiler
tout à l'heure et bien sûr un grand
nombre d'opérateurs de
sa vie au sein des industries
voilà une ya pas de d'armes d'armes et
sain d'esprit d'armement on le sait très
bien la papillote certaine autonomie
il faut avoir une industrie d'armement
qui se respecte la nôtre est plutôt bien
elle a été lancée via le volet financier
l'aéronautique le nucléaire et l'espace
on est devenu leader on est très bon
dans les les pâtes aux porte avions
nucléaire on est venu pendant beaucoup
de domaines est clairement dans les
domaines de haute technologie et bien
sûr on est sur des coopérations
d'ailleurs j'ai un peu chambré il faut
placer mais on essaie de perdre et
coopération qui marche avec les avec les
uns et les autres on a cité le transall
est l'acronyme de transport alliance
avec les allemands l'a400m pouvoir
multinationales
plein de choses comme ça lequel se
marchent et de d'équipement on va voir
justement le défilé des troupes
motorisées qui montre justement certains
nouveaux équipements de l'armée
française et en particulier de l'armée
de terre où auparavant justement en
parlant d' équipements on a vu un
command car avec des tenues de
camouflage et ce sont les nouvelles
tenues camouflage alors surtout les on
va voir cette année le nouveau
camouflage des véhicules de l'armée de
terre donc un brin terre de france donc
fini le camouflage dix centres europe
avec des teintes différentes verte noire
donc des études ont été menées depuis
quelques années pour trouver un
camouflage plus efficace face aux
nouveaux moyens d'acquisition
d'image pour essayer de mieux se
camoufler et surtout à un fonds qui
pourra servir ensuite un camouflage
pourra servir de fonds pour ensuite
mettre des motifs et d'autres couleurs
par dessus donc tous les véhicules de
l'armée de terre cette année seront en
brun terre de france
une nouveauté du défilé de cette année
et ils ne sont pas en uniformes les
militaires qui seront à bord de ces
véhicules mais vous les voyez en tenue
de combat casque lourd gilet pare-balles
armements pour bien voilà pour montrer
la volonté s'inscrire dans le plan
stratégique de l'armée terre voulue par
l'actuel chef d'état major de l'armée de
terre bientôt chef d'état major des
armées le retour d'opérations plus
complexes et l'armée de terre sa mission
première celle des opérations de combat
et donc qui se font dans ses tenues où
on voit bout l'effort qui a été fait sur
les petits équipements au sein de
l'armée de terre
il y à ces véhicules dans des griffons
très visible donc qui remplace les vapes
beaucoup ont connu vient que de la force
navale des états ajoute ben laden évoqué
50 ans et plus et voilà c'est quand on
est néophyte on sait pas la différence
entre un entrain chars et un véhicule de
l'avant blindé
lassé des transports de ces du transport
de troupes
sous blindage avec un peu d'armement
mais c'est surtout s'approcher des zones
de combat tout en étant protégé face aux
tirs adverses face aux mines dont il ya
des portes à l'arrière et les des
troupes peuvent se mettre derrière se
mettre à l'intérieur et être protégé
c'est climatisé et contrairement à la
génération précédente
voilà la petite précision tout à l'heure
en parlant de l'armée de l'air j'avais
dit que le zew a eu avec acquis des
rafales et c'est bien des mirages qui
disent on voit la petite correction mais
c'est bien des avions fournis par de
célèbres français derrière les wc du
92ème régiment d'infanterie le régime en
auvergne le régiment de clermont ferrand
les bébés c'est y qui depuis 2008 sont
déployés en opérations avec satisfaction
et un canon au dessus des merveilles de
précision lors des opérations de combat
qui sont menées en afghanistan liban au
sahel
un bébé c'est un véhicule blindé là
aussi ou à l'arrière on en marque un
groupe de fantassins et qui peut
s'approcher au plus près des adversaires
je remercie kriss kross qui nous donne
ce pense bête c'est simple pourtant il
n'ya pas de canon long sur 1 v abe donc
effectivement ça peut être un moyen de
reconnaître merci chris kraus de 7,2
cette précision vous parez vous
précisiez justement les rafales qui sont
effectivement fabriqués par par dassault
le groupe dassault est propriétaire
également du figaro et il ya cette
question de ziggy
les rafales sont des rafales qui ont été
vendus à la croatie sens sans
remplacement
il revient souvent sur 7 sur cette
information effectivement des avions qui
sont souvent et on a également vu
d'autres questions comme ça sur d'autres
équipements qui sont vendus à d'autres à
d'autres pays mais sans que parfois ce
soit
remplacé pour l'armée française on
prélève dans les stocks de l'armée
française mais il n'y a pas de
remplacement par l'armée française et
des rafales d'occasions donc ont été
vendus à la croatie est la grèce
récemment à la grèce un contrat était
pour ce qui es tu partais pour la grèce
un contrat a été passé pour les
remplacer point par point pour la
croatie des réflexions sont actuellement
en cours avec des options permettant
l'acquisition de moyens autres que les
rafales mais c'est à dire tout ce qui
est potes de désignation tout ce qui est
moyen mais ken tout ce qui est pièces de
rechange et tout ça pour permettre vous
avions déjà acquis deux volets et puis
peut-être que dans un deuxième temps
dans ce qu'on appelle leur prochaine loi
de programmation militaire
un contrat en bonne et due forme sera
signée pour remplacer point par point
ces rafales d'occasion vendus à des pays
à d'autres pays donc voilà des
réflexions qui sont encore en cours là
dessus sur ce point le défilé motorisé
continue alors oui avec un grand groupe
d'artillerie mixte devant nous avec
différents matériels ou clark iris et
ceux qui envoient les obus fort et loin
ce qui frappe fort ce qui aura pouvoir
de masser de destruction important donc
les césar les canons caesar qui ont fait
des merveilles face à l'état islamique
en irak y en syrie il ya quelques années
voilà qui sont aurélie effectivement
dans le tordeur dégrade au nord de
l'irak qui est en voie d une trentaine
de kilomètres et derrière des
chemillé dlr rulence faut peut-être
unitaire qui envoient des roquettes avec
une précision métrique c'est à dire que
ça ça touche la cible de façon
extrêmement précise
dans les 70 km voilà la france en
disposant 13 donc c'est un échantillon
une capacité échantillonneur mais on
dispose certes pas beaucoup elle est rue
et on a une pensée puisque c'était le
mont igman qui étaient signalés pour
ceux qui sont morts et qui ont servi aux
morts au mont igman dans les années 90
au dessus de sarajevo dans les balkans
guère que connaît très bien conflit que
connais très bien la mayral koldo fille
vous y était vous étiez à ce moment là
on va y revenir le groupement de
recherche multi capteurs là maintenant
alors juste devant nous la le pas depuis
qu'il ya ces éléments de transmission là
qui passe donc seule arme qui relie les
arbres de transmissions pour que tout le
monde puisse savoir où en est on se met
les ordres et puis juste derrière on
parler d'unité haddock qui qui défilent
donc le groupement de recherche multi
capteurs c'est le groupement de moyens
de l'armée de terre de renseignement qui
comprend à la fois des capacités de
drones on va les voir défiler c'est la
première fois qu'ils vont défiler ses
petits drones les drones s mdr qui
permettent de voir au delà de la colline
comme on dit donc un grm qui rentre tout
juste ce que ses racines un groupement
de recherche multi capteurs dont qui
rentre tout juste d'opérations au sahel
commandé par le chef du corps du 61ème
ira donc différents moyens
le chef de corps derrière des quads et
des bébés elle qu'il est du 2e régiment
de hussards qui permettent de faire du
renseignement sont spécialisés dans le
renseignement humain c'est-à-dire avec
l'entretien ou par observations sont
capables de s'infiltrer de repérer des
cibles à haute valeur ajoutée
de durer longtemps sur le terrain
derrière on voit les drones voilà sur le
leurs remorques dsm des airs qui ont été
déployés il ya quelques mois au sel
nouveaux moyens et puis derrière des
capacités très particulière des
capacités de guerre électronique c'est à
dire 4 téléréseau adverse
éventuellement les brouilles et repérer
où ils sont et puis ensuite pouvoir
délivrer des les écouter pouvoir
délivrer éventuellement des frappes des
moyens très près de haute technologie
demandant des compétences complexes
longue à acquérir et qui permettent
aujourd'hui lors des opérations
notamment lors de l'opération de barkan
voilà de donner des coordonnées de
trouver des cibles et pouvoir ensuite
avec d'autres moyens
l'armée de l'air l'armée de terre
pouvoir frapper l'adversaire voilà il
faut chercher les intentions de
l'adversaire
ensuite engager des opérations tout à
l'heure à venir à l'école de filles vous
parlez de vous parler des missiles de
croisière qu'elle est là quelle distance
peut parcourir un missile de croisière
jusqu'à 1000 km à combien de kilos mais
la précision inférieure aux maîtres
supérieur d'une fenêtre il ya une autre
question qui est posée sur les sur les
sur les équipements
à l'instant par kriss kross qui regrette
puisqu'on voit les justement ces
véhicules légers que l'armée française
est abandonné ce qu'on appelait les p4
qui ne sont pas les gens qui étaient
réformer au service militaire ne faisait
que les moins de vingt ans ne peut pas
comprendre mais que
les moins de 40 ans et
les les p4 donc c'était un véhicule
la climatisation grâce aux fenêtres des
véhicules âgés anciens qui je pense que
beaucoup de conducteurs se rappellent de
leur capacité de freinage toute relative
de la p4 des véhicules anciens qui ont
été remplacés donc par vt4 on envoie une
justement on voit un véhicule vtk
justement coincé entre ses deux camions
là qui sont des nouveaux véhicules qui
sont ne sont pas français voilà qui sont
si l'on construit à l'étranger mais
transformés en france du côté de saint
nazaire quand je crois qu'ils voilà qui
reçoivent des équipements pour les
militarisée et qui reçoivent ces
équipements en france
oui et c'est une question peut-être
également pour l'amiral col de filles
vous disiez tout à l'heure que l'une des
spécificités de l'industrie militaire
française de il a été notamment des
bleus c'est qu'elle a été notamment
développé par le général de gaulle à une
époque où la france prenait son son
autonomie stratégique l'histoire de
l'industrie militaire française c'est
également l'histoire de la souveraineté
et de l'autonomie de l'autonomie
française exactement d'ailleurs la dgr
vient dé ses 60 ans on est bien là à ce
tournant qui était celui de la
dissuasion et puis de l'autonomie dans
les secteurs stratégiques étaient les
secteurs de l'espace id2 de
l'aéronautique
donc on voit les résultats une ambition
une impulsion politique forte des moyens
et 50 ans plus tard soixante ans plus
tard on est dans le peloton de tête
mondial
je pense que c'est un exemple qui
pourrait servir à l'époque où on trouve
avec le cyber espace cyber guerre les
étendues océanique l'espace proprement
dit on a on a des moyens de avec une
forte volonté politique de continuer à
être non pas les champions pour être le
champion mais les champions pour mieux
se défendre lui mieux protéger les les
les français je voudrais juste faire une
incidente sur tous les matériels de
l'armée de terre que l'on vient de voir
matériel roulant
on ressent pas peut-être à paris
toute une génération d'équipements citer
les les villes les gabella mix10 le le
rcm ex didacte un étang à charrat je le
précise aux internautes mois moins férus
de l'édition militaires de l'armée de
terre à conserver elysées jusqu'à la
corde parce que je n'ai pas les moyens
de se renouveler ont été renouvelés sont
en train d'être renouvelée par un
gigantesque programme qui s'appelle
scorpions qui qui comprend on a vu les
griffons il y aura aussi des les jaguars
le portant levée pelles à le porter le
petit véhicule
ces équipements cas présent des sommes
considérables ans je peux pas faire de
comparaison ils sont en train de donner
à notre armée de terre des capacités
nouvelles de mobilité de combat de
protection et d'intervention là on est
on est vraiment j'avais dire une rupture
entre eux ceux de la guerre froide et
post guerre froide et et ceux de demain
avec également les chars les leclerc
rénové là on a un peu plus de 200
actuellement et qui vont être rénovés
pour les combats futurs là on a vraiment
le trouve que le chef de l'armée de
terre ministre après tout la haute
hiérarchie et tous les toute l'armée de
terre chemise aura pour avoir des
équipements modernes efficaces et qui
correspondent mieux
alors bien sûr en petites quantités ce
qu'on n'a pas de moyens de faire de
grandes séries mais de couvrir tous les
domaines d'intervention le service de
l'énergie opérationnel anciens qui était
un bon baptisé avant qu'ils étaient
service des essences des armées
donc ceux qui permettent de de
transporter et d'apporter les notamment
les fruits de carburant vers les unités
opérationnelles et demain peut-être
d'autres énergies c'est le sait le sens
de ceux de ce changement de nom entre
service des essences des armées essaris
des notes de l'énergie opérationnel
aujourd'hui le programme scorpion nous
disaient qu'ils avaient été lancées par
jean claude rey
quand il me semble
brillant mérite selon lui d'être à
l'honneur alors ce qui est vrai c'est
que le programme scorpion avait été
lancé par l'état major de l'armée de
terre à l'époque dirigée par le général
rac madou si je m'amuse et qui avait été
lancée sur sur dix ans pour justement
faire pièce peut-être à d'autres armes
et notamment la marine où l'armée de
l'air qui eux ont des gros programmes
d'armement et l'armée de terre se
plaignait à l'époque de ne pas avoir un
d'être toujours celle qu'on rogne parce
que c'est là où il ya les petites
dépenses et donc il fallait faire de
rassembler les achats pour faire des
grosses dépenses
le programme scorpion de tels programmes
d'armement en fait s'inscrivent dans un
temps donc c'était même avant jean yves
le drian que les premières réflexions
sas à 15 ans avant de déboucher dès les
premières commandes
quel gars nous dit sauf le programme à
15 ans de retard alors on aimerait bien
on aimerait les militaires auraient sans
doute que ça arrive plus vite c'est
évident surtout que les les comme le
disait l'amiral les matériels sont usés
jusqu'à la corde donc scorpions
s'inscrire voilà il ya quinze ans les
premières réflexions lancées
officiellement les premières commandes
sous le ministre le drian et puis des
commandes qui arrive sans doute petit à
petit dans les forces donc comme disait
l'amiral des premiers blindés à partir
de l'année prochaine les premiers chars
légers
tout ça arrive petit à petit au sein des
forces on va retourner dans sur les
champs elysées si on l'entend brune
d'audrey toujours skis pas que il ya un
peu de grabuge il s'entendra de se faire
sortir donc si vous êtes encore là eh
ben on vous retrouve pour dire que au
contraire on a toujours besoin de vous
et que les internautes attendent de
savoir justement comment ça s'est passé
de votre côté tu préfères qu'il se mette
tous les deux du même côté alors vous me
détestez du 14 juillet la police est en
train de le faire si l'on doit quitter
le périmètre de sécurité
mais juste un instant avant de partir je
suis donc avec anaïs anaïs bonjour
bonjour vous venez d'où anaïs on vient
de brest dans le finistère très bien et
françois bonjour bonjour alors je veux
juste une petite question qu'est ce que
vous avez pensé vous êtes avec vos deux
fils bonjour qu'est ce que vous avez
pensé du défilé on va demander à
mademoiselle donc bon pour votre fils et
les chevaux de la garde républicaine
qu'elle a préféré et vous madame dans à
peu près tous après c'est vrai qu'on
était surtout venu voir les pompiers
alors vous êtes pompiers vous êtes
pompiers ou du coup quel dans le
finistère le design et vos collègues
dont vous avez applaudi vos collègues de
paris notamment
exactement ça ça j'avais quatre
collègues qui défilaient
du 19 et les collègues de paris et
plusieurs régions des filets en tant
qu'étranger ème bataillon des bouviers
et c'est la première fois que vous êtes
à paris pour le défilé du 14 juillet
ouais c'est la première fois en
profitent des vacances pour pour sauter
sur l'occasion du défilé et des
festivités du 14 juillet est-ce que vous
reviendrai oh bah oui sûrement
et mis à part me zappeurs donc faux
collègues pompiers est ce qu'il ya
quelque chose qui vous a impressionné
qu'est ce que vous avez retenu
particulièrement les gros véhicules de
l'armée qui passait là les pompiers
c'était impressionnant
c'est qu'après de voir tous les
uniformes après c'est quelque chose de
différent mais à la télé mais bon
français en revanche baissé sur un
rapprochement mettait en valeur que ça
vous vois qu'on voit que tu mens pas
[Musique]
merci beaucoup analysé françois pour
vous laisser partir à poney nous sommes
les derniers de se connaître on doit
vous laisseront pas rentrer en tout cas
le défi n'est très précieux
[Musique]
notamment
c'est très belle entente
à bientôt sur le volet merci beaucoup
brune
on va rester un peu en direct nous avec
les images que nous transmettent la fp
et effectivement la garde républicaine
juste peut-être un mot
juste un mot flanc je suis très étonné
de voir que déjà la police évacue les
personnes qui sont soit chance de viser
alors même qu'on était en train de le
voir le défilé lui n'est pas terrien oui
et tout en haut des champs-elysées donc
vraiment loin de la place de la concorde
à première vue les gens sortent
peut-être des questions de sécurité il
ya des gros dispositif de sécurité mis
en place et donc peut-être pour
faciliter la levée de ce dispositif il
est
les gens sont sont mis dehors c'est vrai
que l'aspect festif à un cavalier qui
est tombé de la garde républicaine qui
est en train de tenir son choix un peu
d'agitation toujours très compliqué même
s'ils sont bien éduqué formé
c'est toujours une autre paire de
manches que de les faire défiler au les
faire défiler calmement
nous voilà donc des spectateurs qui fait
un peu fine y est donc ils sont
rapidement sortis de ce dispositif de
sécurité
effectivement on voit le cheval lui
partir dans une scène digne de du roman
de jean raspail ici partir ça se passe à
cet endroit là à l'arrière du répondeur
les fanfares et est effectivement comme
pas traumatisant mais ça c'est complexe
à gérer pour les gardes républicains
puis les pavés qui sont pas forcément
toujours apprécié des sabots des chevaux
qui font que ça reste un exercice qui a
beau être préparés longtemps à l'avant
ce qui reste un exercice compliqué
réponse à tout choeur les soldats
français font-ils des 35 heures aussi et
bien non on y rit on a abordé cette
question justement en début de live
et la commission européenne
et fait pression sur la france en ce
moment pour que
les france l'essonne les militaires
français soit mis sous le régime des 35
heures et emmanuel macron à
justement rejeter encore hier cette
éventualité cette possibilité c'est la
fin du défilé effectivement c'est le
tableau de clôture l'hommage à la
jeunesse engagée c'est en tout cas le
le thème qui est affiché tu as fait
alors donc hélas l'amiral pourra sans
doute plus développés on voit apparaître
derrière cette
cette musique des troupes de marine des
représentants des différents services et
et dispositif mis en place en faveur de
la jeunesse
je la suis peut-être la meilleure cmev
lever ses nus toi oui
l'amiral col de fille peut peut-être
nous justement l'europe repréciser un
petit peu tous eu tout ce dispositif
oui un ensemble de ce qu'il reste qu'ils
sont en phase de développement on a
évoqué le service national universel
il ya également le service civique il ya
le service militaire volontaire
je parle pas des volontaires qui
s'engagent dans les armées et donc c'est
tout un ensemble de dispositions qui
montre bien que pour pallier l'absence
de suspension du service militaire et
donner un cadre général de vie en
société à nos jeunes garçons et filles
majeures si possible parce que la presse
d'autres problèmes quand ils sont
mineurs des initiatives se se développe
pour le moment ça donne pas l'impression
d'un ensemble disponibles coordonnées
chacun travaille dans son coin
moi je rappelle que les décorés de la
légion d'honneur dans le pré de la
société et 50000 nous travaillons dans
ses différentes des directions que
d'autres n'est pas les seuls avec avec
beaucoup beaucoup de jeunes
ça me paraît important tout ça en train
de monter en puissance je crois qu'il
faut pas vouloir arriver à la fin de
l'étape avant d'avoir parcouru les
différents col de l'étape de montagne il
faut que nous ayons des personnels
encadrants des budgets beaucoup de
volontariat ça pose ça repose sur
beaucoup de bénévolat de l'ancien ça se
fait dans tous les sens ce serait pas
par exemple je vais faire venir aux
invalides la secrétaire d'état à la
jeunesse soient ses nus et ses madame et
les rires qui va les olympiades
marqué un peu le coin je l'espère
marquer un peu le territoire de ce
qu'ont fait ou vis-à-vis de notre
jeunesse
mais il faut créer le l'entraînement en
suffisant pour que tout le monde adore
l'idée ce qui est de plus en plus de
jeunes qu'ils soient attirés par ces
différentes possibilités de battre
convention a travaillé à savoir vivre
ensemble
voilà justement ces jeunes amiral on les
voit en ce moment dans ce tableau et
finale sur la place place de la concorde
effectivement ils sont extrêmement jeune
on regarde ce tableau final et on y
revient juste après si vous voulez bien
oui bien sûr on peut
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui
et
voilà plusieurs morceaux de variétés
qu'ils sont interprétés par ces jeunes
et qu'ils vont interpréter la
marseillaise on pourra l'entendre juste
ensuite s'il admire alcool de figue nous
entend également
donc on rappelle cette initiative que
vous prenez donc dans le cas de la
société les manques de la légion
d'honneur sur les olympiades de la
jeunesse qui aura lieu au mois de
septembre
le trench septembre exactement le 26
peut-être peut-être une autre une autre
question qui est posée rapidement
peut-être par par cet internaute qui
nous dit est-ce qu'on peut aborder la
question des problèmes liés à l'usure
accélérée des pièces que seul alors là
le sahel oui c'est un théâtre
d'opération particulièrement exigeant
que ça soit les températures les
changements de température du très chaud
là je voterai froid la nuit parfois et
puis le sable qui s'insèrent partout et
donc qui conduit à une usure accélérée
des matériels la mécanique n'aime pas le
sam n'aime pas les changements de
température
donc c'est très exigeant il ça demande
beaucoup d'entretien donc là il ya un an
on peut on peut parler aussi de ses
mécaniciens pas forcément beaucoup mis
en avant lors de défilés mais sont
pourtant indispensables que ce soit les
mécaniciens pour les véhicules blindés
les mécaniciens pour les avions les
mécaniciens pour les hélicoptères qui
font un travail formidable dans l'ombre
jour et nuit parfois tard parfois les
conditions compliquées qui permettent de
maintenir ces véhicules mais oui le
sahel conduit à une usure accélérée de
ses matériels du fait des conditions
merci vous êtes nuit dans les bars cafés
s'il vous plaît la première c'est sur
l'échelle les conditions d'engagement de
nos troupes
essentiellement à terre dans les
conditions climatiques difficiles à fait
que nous en avons fini avec le
moins-disant dans les passations de
marché sur les vêtements les chaussures
les plus hauts vers les gants et cetera
qui était un peu la doctrine des vies
ministère des finances
quand il s'agit de passer des marchés
donc maintenant on est on est revenus y
compris pour ses équipements de base au
mieux disant les conditions normales
mais nos soldats ont souffert de ses
affaires au rabais dans l'est dans des
pays voisins d'ailleurs mais qui
proposait des choses moins cher la
deuxième chose je voulais revenir sur
les lycées militaires de la défense
parce que amiral jusqu'après le tableau
avant tout fille finale où on va
peut-être avoir le voilà un tableau
final contre 1 2
voilà donc en train d'assister en direct
et la marseillaise
on y reviendra avec vous je remercie
florent de saint victor qui étaient avec
nous le blog mars attacks on va le
mettre remettre dans le bain le chat et
on va revenir on va conclure également
avec l'amiral paul ii fit ensuite et
nicolas nicolas barotte merci beaucoup
le blog marsatac avec une information un
récit exclusif sur la une performance
des forces spéciales en afghanistan et
ses ouvertures de sites donc voix
demanderez adrien brillant de le mettre
effectivement en dans le tchat
il a déjà été mis mais on va le remettre
dans le dans le château un petit peu
curieux d'ailleurs cette cette scène qui
se passe devant la devant la tribune
officielle avec on voit bien brigitte
macron et quelques ministres qui tape
qui tape dans l'est dans les mains c'est
destiné donc à toujours à marquer
la présence donc de l'engagement de la
jeunesse ça ça fait là on repère les
différents uniformes l'amiral en parler
donc les jeunes sapeurs pompiers les
lycées militaires de la défense il y
reviendra avec leurs vestes et leurs
insignes que ce soit la flèche saint cyr
l'école ex autun on voit les membres du
service militaire volontaire avec leur
casquette du sn eu avec le smv avec
leurs calots le la nuit avec leurs
casquettes voilà différents différents
dispositifs qui font une un tableau
bigard est effectivement l'un devant les
fanfares de l'élément des fanfares
notamment de ces lycées militaires
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
oh non
[Musique]
pourtant les eaux
le
[Musique]
et
c
marché
[Musique]
oh
il
[Musique]
à
ans
or
[Musique]
aux oreilles
haut et fort ce
faux drapeau pour cent
[Musique]
c
à
le rang 6 euros
[Musique]
nous écoutons
c'est
et
le
m
[Musique]
à
où
[Musique]
de suivre en direct donc cette
marseillaise chantée à plusieurs couples
et dont le dernier le premier et le
dernier par un choeur de 132 jeunes et
avec également un combo musique de la
brigade des sapeurs-pompiers de paris
des instrumentistes issus des fanfares
des lycées militaires sous la conduite
du lieutenant colonel stéphane fougeroux
chef de la musique des troupes de marine
et accompagné bien sûr du choeur de
l'armée française
on voit effectivement le président de la
république qui reçoit les salutations du
gouverneur militaire de paris le général
christophe abad et sans doute qui va
aller saluer ces jeunes du service
civique des lycées militaires
bonjour nicolas barotte re bonjour
bonjour on est content de vous retrouver
le bernard new deal et c'était très beau
de l'entendre cette marseillaise on va
justement retrouve avoir un petit peu
votre regard sur ceux sur ce défilé
il ya des questions aussi pas mal de
questions qui sont revenus pendant le
chaton ne va pas aborder et on va y
revenir parce que je pense que c'est
important que vous puissiez y répondre
et apporter justement votre regard de
correspondants défense et on va croiser
ça avec le regard et les réponses de
l'amiral coldefy amiral col de fille
justement par dont je vous ai coupé tout
à l'heure vous ne disiez quelque chose
d'assez important sur justement la
formation de la jeunesse et des lycées
militaires mais alors oui je voulais
parler des lycées militaires de la
défense dont les quatre ont été cités
tout à l'heure et en particulier du
prytanée militaire de la flèche parce
que moi je suis un ancien élève et un
ancien président des anciens élèves mais
ces jeunes sous les ouvriers vont
préparer ça n'a pas l'air saint cyr le
général de cointe le général la vie nous
virale de billy et général puga grand
chancelier général georgelin le général
quel chien lanxade enfin la plupart de
nos élites
le nouveau chef d'état major de l'armée
de terre général chine sont passés par
le prytanée militaire
quand je fais un peu plus la pub que le
que les autres parce que c'est mon
ancien lycée et ces jeunes là vont aller
en maths sup maths spé pour reprendre
les anciens les anciens vocable préparer
ces grands concours ainsi que des
concours et concours civile c'est là que
se retrouvent une grande partie de nos
futurs champions et je pense qu'on peut
tirer leur chapeau merci et ben voilà
c'est fait c'est chose faite et bien sûr
une salutation à tous ses élèves de ces
lycées militaires et tous ceux qui vont
rentrer à partir de la fin de l'été en
prépa pour toute ces
et pour notamment pour les écoles et les
grandes écoles
nicolas barotte qu'est ce que vous
retenez des images qu'on a vu qu'on
continue de voir on voit d'ailleurs le
président de la république donc saluer
les choeurs de l'armée française
de ceux de ce défilé qu'est ce qui vous
a marqué la normale et c'est plutôt
positif
il faut le comparer avec l'année
dernière avec ce défilé confinés sur la
place de la concorde
sans foule son public fantomatique assez
étrange
là on retrouve la symbolique du 14
juillet les champs elysées les gens aux
abords que va applaudir les soldats et
c'est important parce que le 14 juillet
sauf une place particulière dans
l'imaginaire français c'est le lien
armée nation qui se concrétise avec les
militaires et la population qui se
retrouvent pour un peu communier et
c'est très important ce lien c'est un
peu consubstantiels de l'identité
nationale
l'armé de la france c'est la mère de la
nation c'est la nation en arbre c'est
c'est ce qu'on hérite de la révolution
française notamment
vous répondez d'ailleurs à cette
question sur le lien entre l'armée et la
révolution française c'est sous la
révolution française qu'on voit pour la
première fois la conscription c'est à
dire la l'obligation pour tous les
jeunes hommes d'aller faire d'entrée à
un moment ou un autre dans les armées
c'est la bataille de valmy qui symbolise
ce moment où le peuple défense des
fournisseurs et c'est par contre on a
mis fin c'est jacques chirac qui a mis
fin à 7 à cette construction au début
des années 2000 même si on y est revenue
abondamment pendant tous direct il y à
un certain nombre de dispositifs le
service militaire volontaire ou service
national universel est également le
dispositif qu'on voit également en outre
vers en outre mer le service militaire
adapté
il y à une question qui revient qui est
beaucoup revenus c'est sûr les
concernant les équipements et notamment
une question est ce qu'il faudrait pas
un deuxième porte avions
et pourquoi pas des avions ravitailleurs
des transports et des bpc c'est à dire
des des appels des mistral dans le
jargon des bâtiments des bâtiments de
projection et de commandement
la réponse est oui mais pour faire bon
coup il faut beaucoup de moyens
le problème c'est que les capacités
financières de la france soit limitée
donc il faut choisir
c'est la conséquence quand même deux
décennies de gestion déficitaire de
crise économique
maria est ensuite est-ce que le pin up
accepterait qu'on consacre 3 4% du pib
aux armées c'est encore autre chose dans
tout le papier oui il faudrait deux
porte-avions patron a les moyens de
payer aux en équipement s'est passé pas
certain martin alors pour pallier ce
manque
emma la seule solution c'est d'avoir des
alliances et c'est pour ça qu'un des
grands mots que les armes et utilise
aujourd'hui c'est l'interopérabilité
c'est un peu un barbarisme mais bon ça
signifie bien que pouvoir faire face aux
grands enjeux de demain face aux deux
grands adversaires qui peuvent être la
russie ou la livre pourrait paraître
nombre plusieurs la france ne pourra pas
amiral col de filles est ce que c'est
votre point de vue également est ce que
il ya la nécessité de ces équipements et
en particulier vous qui avez commandé un
porte avions parce qu'il ya la nécessité
d'un deuxième porte avions selon vous et
puis est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
ce que dit nicolas c'est à dire que
peut-être yat-il nécessité mais on n'a
pas les moyens et donc il faut trouver
des alliances avec avec des partenaires
étrangers
alors c'est une nécessité parce que si
vous voulez un porte avions disponibles
et en faut deux séries dans les anglais
ont consommé 2 tout le monde tout le
monde on construit par un nombre
supérieur ou égal à 2 quand on peut se
douter c'est de cette capacité que d'une
capacité surtout avec le rafale est le
hawk acquis une capacité de le
déplacement sans avoir à survoler
terrain sans avoir à se poser sans le
voir et c'est pendant des semaines et
des semaines
le deuxième point c'est est ce que les
budgets le permettent oui c'est pas un
investissement je connaissais les les le
rap les rapports des budgets le rapport
des équipements donc ce serait
inutilement polémique que d'en parler
ici mais on en a largement les capacités
financières
3 est-ce qu'il faut des coopérations oui
il faut l'interopérabilité elle est à la
fois dans les états majors et dans les
équipements dans les états majors elles
existent parce que ça fait on n'a jamais
quitté j'allais dire
l'otan et la façon de travailler de nos
alliés et pratiqué dans l'armée de l'air
et de la marine
on sait travailler avec eux depuis 70
ans pas de souci c'était un peu plus
compliqué parce que les armées sur le
terrain ne sont pas mélangés
ils ont des dispositifs géographique
dispersé donc donc ça on le fait sur les
équipements c'est plus compliqué parce
que on a on avait déjà parlé les
industries d'armement sont les
industries de souveraineté et les pays
ont de la difficulté à donner
j'allais dire à coopérer parce que à
chaque fois il ya du développement de
l'innovation de la techno de la haute
technologie est là bien sûr on touche au
coeur au coeur du coeur donc c'est un
petit peu plus difficile
et dernier point l'interopérabilité plus
l'interopérabilité classique que l'on a
connu des équipements des avions des
bateaux tout pouvait se ravitailler
qui dirait la même cartouche et cetera
c'était d'interopérabilité qui touchent
le domaine du cybermonde de la
cyberguerre de l'intelligence
artificielle de la capacité à gérer des
situations complète donc tous les
domaines pas seulement vis du terme
dans tous ces domaines et ça c'est un
petit peu plus compliqué mais je pense
que nos armées
ils vont assez résolument et que bien
sûr on peut toujours être voir le verre
à moitié plein ça m'est égal
mais je pense que en tout cas elles ont
elles ont vu j'allais dire les enjeux
les défis qu'il fallait relever que
celle ci mette cela dit on vient de
traverser une crise qui dont on va payer
les conséquences économiques
alors que tout le monde se serre la
ceinture donc n'ayons pas les yeux plus
gros que le vent pour le moment où le
moment si j'avais une comparaison à
faire on a une équipe une de haute volée
dans toutes les dimensions de toutes nos
armées mais aucun remplaçant sur le banc
de touche
donc voilà il faut qu'on reconstitue les
forces mais le faire doucement au rythme
de nos capacités financières
merci pour eux pour cette réponse pour
ces précisions
juste peut être un arrêt sur images le
président de la république qui est en
train de discuter donc avec des
personnes qui ont assisté dans l'est
dans les tribunes au défilé on ne sait
pas trop ce qui est en train de dire est
ce qu'il s'agit d'une famille de
militaires morts en opération ou bien
des personnes blessées on va en tout cas
le président qui a commencé à parler
sans masque avec
son épouse qui est l est et l est
les interlocuteurs qui était aussi qui a
finalement mis au cours de la
conversation avec derrière lui le chef
d'état major particulier
l'amiral roland donc longue longue
discussion longue aparté du président de
la république à l'issue de la cérémonie
il ya une question qui a été posée et
qui est que vous avez posé à la fois sur
youtube
vous avez posé à la fois sur le chat du
figaro en tous les cas des remarques qui
sont revenus autour de cette question
on voit ces équipements on voit ses
soldats on voit ces défilés on parle
beaucoup du justement des problématiques
de munitions des problématiques
d'équipement des problématiques
budgétaires
est ce que on a les moyens de faire une
guerre d'intensité de très fortes guerre
avec ses équipements avec ses soldats
aujourd'hui les gens partir de ce qu'a
dit l'amiral un prêt à l'instant l'armée
française elle est plutôt bien équipé et
les complète elle sait à peu près tout
faire son problème c'est qu'on n'a pas
la masse comme disent les militaires
donc on peut faire la guerre mes délires
des guerres courte escale a dit
notamment une analyse de la rand
corporation c'est un think tank anglo
saxons noah un rapport remis récemment
quiquet très bien que l'armée française
est très compétente mais sa durée de vie
sur un terrain militaire
le combat de votre intensité donc pas au
mali contre des terroristes et contre un
adversaire de même puissance que nous
serait très limité parce que nos moyens
sont limités et donc bas dans une guerre
on perd des avions vers des bateaux est
assez vite au bout de quelques jours
on n'aurait plus les moyens de
poursuivre parce que par ce manque
d'équipements et de régénération
d'équipement les militaires prennent
exemple de la guerre des malouines en
disant que face à l'argentine
donc là entre l'argentine et la
grande-bretagne en 1982 et 10%
d'attrition par semaine donc fait le
calcul on va les avions bah ce que vous
appelez l'attrition et l'interdire de la
perte
c'est ça la perte la destruction des
gîtes à chaque fois 10 % de pertes
donc au bout de dizaines de jours il y
avait il n'ya plus assez d'avions pour
mener une guerre si on prend le même
ratio fonds
comme appliqué à l'armée de l'air
aujourd'hui donc on peut faire des
choses dans durée limitée donc on a
trois solutions la guerre éclair le
champ de la montée en puissance des
équipements ou pas faire de guerre du
tout ça peut passer
est ce que c'est votre analyse également
les alcools de fini alors je sur la
troisième fois un fils ou rire pas faire
la guerre du tout c'est pas nous qui
décidons de faire la guerre c'est les
autres qui décide de nous faire la
guerre il faut le rappeler on n'aurait
pas les moyens de faire la guerre non
non non non non vous avez dit
guerre-éclair d'accord j'ai indiqué
qu'on n'avait pas la capacité de durer
serra la zone faire avec les autres ne
pas faire la guerre mais la guerre on ne
la fait pas on la subit ce sont les
autres qui nous attaque
donc il faut bien se préparer à faire la
guerre c'est pas nous qui n'y a aucun
plan 10 ans et tient la paix demain on
va attaquer tel ou tel pays ou telle ou
telle ou telle zone
quels sont les autres qui nous font la
guerre c'est pour ça que c'est un peu
difficile de prévoir la haine
donc pour résumer je rejoins en tout
point ce que vient de dire que la